Kieselbrot 35
easy money abgreifen
hier also ich bin noch nicht sonderlich wach ich bin gar nicht wach also wenn ich auf einmal
nichts mehr sagen dann bin ich eingepennt wieder
ein zekrot ja auch die nacht durchgemacht aber nicht sonderlich gut gepennt
so aber ein klaren tag so erst mal easy money collecten 2k18 das wichtigste easy money ist
immer das beste hat den collector flick gesehen gerade ja logisch mal auf dem wissert und hast
du nicht gepennt doch habe ich aber nicht sonderlich lange und ich so also ich habe
zwar im bett gelegen habe ich viel gepennt so wir müssen noch 200 basis können das war
mal jetzt schnell schön als wissert ist das kann man auch komplett prima machen muss
drei spells klicken und gut ist hallo peri
bett wenn ich verkehr bett futter also jetzt müssen wir noch 200 basis können danach
muss man glaube ich irgendwie noch immer so ein paar mobs killen ob's können kriege
ich auch jetzt hin danach aufwarte placements euch war es in euch aufwarte placements glatt
spielen kann vielleicht nachher wenn er er ist da ist wobei der hat der hat mir vorhin
im discord geschrieben irgendwie um sieben uhr noch ich glaube nicht dass der nächste
dann auftauchte hat geschrieben war placements gemacht hat übelst kacke bis auf die letzte
runde waren leute hier aus dem stream dabei die war gut aber wisst ihr das geile was man
gestern gesehen hat als wir overwatch custom matches gemacht haben ich meine wir hatten
ja wirklich alles dabei also wir hatten wir hatten wir hatten porsche spieler dabei und
top 500 in einem team in einem game also sowas was du normalerweise ja nicht siehst was man
da gesehen hat ist es brauchen aufwarte erst mal gar keinen speziellen rank um im team
zu spielen raus nicht du musst das nur wollen und in diesem normalen ranking modus will
das kaum jemand ja einmal wünscht ihr auch easy clap 2k 18 ich brauche mal wieder neues
fuhrt so viel da eigentlich wollte ich auch noch was für youtube aufnehmen aber das
rutsch erst mal wieder ein bisschen wache werden also wie gesagt wegen overwatch placements
müssen wir mal gucken also wenn schon heute abend ich wusste ich muss übrigens jetzt
gleich nochmal was futtern hier ich habe hier frühstück stehen also ich mute mich mal immer
kurz mal zwischendurch dass ich euch nicht ins ortsschwarzen muss
zumal ja heute der letzte tag ist wo ich urlaub habe or geht mir das auf zack sage
ich euch also ich meine heute hat ja jeder urlaub so ausnahmsweise die leute die vielleicht
im krankenhaus arbeiten und so nicht aber normalerweise die meisten haben heute urlaub und ich hatte
den ganzen december urlaub also quasi von anfang fast vom ersten quasi ich glaube erster
war freitag war letzten tag war ich aber immer im kompletten december war ich jetzt nicht
auf der arbeit ich urlaub und jetzt morgen muss ich dann wieder hin ich habe überhaupt
kein bock aber es ist meistens nur so bis man da ist wenn man dann da ist gehts dann
ist eigentlich normal und man findet das auch überhaupt nicht mehr schlimm zumindest
das bei mir jedes mal weiß nicht wie euch da geht hier gehts immer so richtig auf den
zack wenn letzten tag letzten tag im urlaub denkst du dann quasi alle paar minuten krasse
oder schallt so morgen wieder früh aufstehen auf die arbeit aber kein bock oder wie ist
das bei euch so jetzt kommen jetzt kommen die ersten leute schreiben wahrscheinlich gleich
hartz 4 for life oder sowas im blödsinn ist es switchchat
ich wünsche euch auch alle easy clap 2k18 dass das für euch permanent easy clap ist
wenn es eine sache ist die ich mir vorgenommen habe für 2018 dass ich nicht wieder monatelang
kein youtube videos hochladen sondern so weit aber im december zumindest vielleicht nicht
ganz so viel aber halt regelmäßig das hatte ich natürlich das hatte ich ja früher auch
das hat glaube ich jeder schon dies irgendein mob das hat glaube ich früher jeder gehabt
ich kann ich ich blende den chat mal wieder ein muss das ist weg moment chat quasi bestand
wenn ich den chat ein so chat wo ist der chat hier jetzt wir machen die an die kratzer
wieder größer dann passt die nämlich genau hinter den chat wir machen die kratze mal
so und den chat noch mal noch einen ticken kleiner aber wobei wenn der chat zu klein
ist kann man da gar nicht mehr richtig sehen das ist auch kacke aber mal sowas glaube
ich ganz gut ja da kann ich mich auch daran erinnern als ich in die schule gegangen bin
das hatte ich auch schon ein bisschen ja das letzte mal war halt berufsschule aber jetzt
auch schon 10 jahr oder so her da hatte ich überhaupt keinen bock also das war noch schlimmer
als da also letzter tag quasi war von ferien da hatte ich da hatte ich gar keinen bock
da hatte ich erstens keinen bock irgendwas zu machen da hab ich die ganze zeit drüber
gedanken gemacht hat aber scheiße morgen wieder schule das war es richtig gesagt ich
weiß gar nicht wo ich weniger bock drauf hatte bei der schule so auf die schule an sich oder
auf manche leute oder auf lehrer oder auf generell auf alles hatte ich keinen bock also immer
wenn man ferien hatte danach ging es ja wieder welches paket hast du dir gekauft bei black
desert auch ich weiß gar nicht mehr was es da für pakete gab also ich habe ich habe
ich habe die standalone version also nicht steam was gibt es was gibt es denn für pakete
sag mal was für pakete gibt dann erkenne ich das bestimmt wieder also ich hatte ich hatte
das wo die pferde flöte mit dabei ist falls es nur ein paket gibt wo die pferde flöte
mit dabei ist dann habe ich das geht der aufzug von deinem opa doch nee er geht nicht mehr
der ist auch weg der aufzug vom opa ist weg ich denke der aufzug war geil wo sind mobs
der aufzug war geil das problem ist mit dem aufzug du kannst das dach nicht richtig isolieren
wenn der aufzug wenn du hast ja da du wusstest ja quasi ein loch im boden du brauchst es
ja ein loch im boden wo der aufzug durchfährt und das konnte man nicht richtig isolieren
das dach war eh schon nicht richtig isoliert weil es im endeffekt haben wir jetzt einfach
den boden so eine isolationsschicht dran gemacht das ist jetzt hier auch viel wärmer
als noch früher einfach nur weil das dach halbwegs isoliert ist also da wo keine heizung
ist aber der aufzug vom opa der war schon geil vor allem wenn man sich überlegt dass
dass er das ja selbst gebaut hat ich mein wer hat man sich im haus den aufzug aufs dach
wahrscheinlich die wenigsten aber der opa war schon kreativ für die leute die nicht
wissen wovon ich rede falls es war schon nicht so lange beziehungsweise nicht so nicht auf
youtube waren oder nicht das video kennt soll ich euch meinen ich habe ja ein video davon
gemacht soll ich euch meinen aufzug zeigen den der opa gebaut hat aufs dach übelst
abenteuerliches ding kann ich euch irgendwie 30 sekunden video zeigen ja wollen alle die
die schon da sind jetzt so viele basis für den wizard so viel in der wand gestackte basis
der gleich haben wir es und wisst ihr was das beste ist wir machen das gleiche danach
noch mal weil das ist eine daily die habe ich gestern angenommen und ich weiß nicht
genau wie sich das verhält ob ich dailies die ich gestern angenommen habe und heute
abgeben einfach heute noch mal machen kann wahrscheinlich nicht aber da müssen wir noch
katri und zentaur daily machen
dort die auch die dover
ja mal kurz ein bisschen was von meinem freundchen gerade fordern
ja direkt live dann habe ich das ich habe das paket mit der verletzter
hast du schon mal escape vom tag auf gespielt deine meinung er hat nicht gespielt ist es
nicht hat man nicht dass ich das jetzt verwechselt das ist kein bettel royale spiel oder das
ist eher so ein wie ist das andere operation fack wie ist das andere game rising storm das
denn dieses bisschen realistischere im zweiten weltkrieg rising storm ne ist das rising storm
ist das denn red orchestra mal genau ist es nicht so ein bisschen wie das gewesen
ein paar welche bafut sind wir das eigentlich da
oder ist escape vom tag auch engelbettel royale spiel dann verwechsel ich das nämlich ich
habe irgendwie im hinterkopf dass es so ein bisschen dass es kein bettel royale ist dass
es schon länger als diesen bettel royale hype gibt dass es eher so ein bisschen auf realistisch
survival stills gemacht ist wenn es das ist dann dann habe ich glaube ich gerade im kopf
was welches game das war
weil der energie so muss das sein
ja ist auf survival realismus gemacht ja ich glaube dann weiß ich was das war aber wie
gesagt gespielt habe ich so nicht es gibt schon eine weile das war ja auch early access
und ich habe es in letzter zeit ein paar leute auch auf twitch spielen sehen was mich vermuten
lässt es ist nicht mehr early access ist es jetzt erschienen mittlerweile
hessisch abel abel x3
mal die fasis abgeben
ich habe ein größeres update ist es jetzt erschienen also ist es jetzt raus
was haben wir sonst noch zum abgeben ach wir haben gestern die country daily gar nicht abgegeben
bin ich blöd dann reiten wir mal kurz hier nach altinova und zählen unser ganzen shit
bescheuert ist wie ich das mache das ist ja besser ich nehme es raus überlade mich und
reiten mit dem pferd weiter hat immer noch beta status ok ich kann mich noch dran erinnern
dass es vor ein paar jahren schon da war ist da schon ein paar leute gespielt haben also
ist es mal eines der early access spiele die wirklich noch entwickelt wird das ist alles
schlecht also es werden ja viele early access spiele nur sehr halbherzig wird dann irgendwie
rausgehauen wird dann irgendwie rausgehauen und manchmal habe ich das gefühl heute so
bei den games je unfertiger und beschissener quasi den early access spiel rauskommt umso
mehr chancen hat es irgendwie so funny let's play zu werden und jeder kauft sich sondern
kümmert sich der entwickler nochmal drum was die katze im bild macht die verdeckt den
chat die katze verdeckt den ingame chat weil nicht unbedingt jeder aus der gilde will
dass man jetzt alles sieht was sie schreiben die verdeckt den ingame chat und ist hintergrund
für den twitch chat
immer noch besser als dates stand alone ja dates ist ja auch ein kacke mittlerweile
es war zur richtigen zeit da dayset vor allem die mod version hat da auch viele anhänger
gehabt aber mit der stand alone version haben sie es halt richtig verkackt also richtig
massiv verkackt
spielt das überhaupt noch jemand dates hat das die coolen leute sagen oder ich sag ja
immer mit dates all zum startbattle viel ne ich bin müde ich muss mobscribe das kriege
ich gerade noch so hin ja genau der armor mod der muss ja wohl immer noch mehr bieten
als die stand alone version das ist eigentlich auch schon lächerlich so ne moment ich muss
erst mal mein loot verkaufen ich bin verwirrt aber mein erst mal luzell überladene wizard
ich will das selten hier zack haben wir da alles weeds haben wir da weeds weeds 420 ja
ich will das selten aber nicht selten basis scale aber selten ganz anderen krempel auch
selbst an armor 3 machen die fast nichts mehr ja ich glaube die zeit von dates hat ist einfach
vorbei es gibt ja mittlerweile auch genug andere survival spiele und zombie survival
das ist ja sowas von 2015 2016 eigentlich heute das ist der loot heute spielen sie ja
alle heute spielen sie alle jahre battle royale ich wusste gar nicht dass ich noch 50 millionen
in altino warum liegen habe das sehr praktisch das ist sehr praktisch so als würde den kram
erst mal marketplace registrieren er denkt den kann man noch selten der goers andere
das schmeiße in wald rein bis inventar space kriegen ja was denn das ach irgendein
kammer zeug kammer sylvia item was auch immer so dann setzen wir den ganzen krempel in marketplace
nur vielleicht gibt es in der nächsten armor 4 könnte ja sein
armor ist durch diese ganze mods die es da so gegeben hat viel erfolgreicher geworden
als sie sich das glaube ich ursprünglich gedacht haben weil armor an sich also das
so die grundversion ja das ist ja schon für richtig hardcore simulations leute
das lohnt sich doch eigentlich auch mit reinzusetzen oder mehr money als beim händler gibt es
auf jeden fall muss ich aufpassen dass ich nicht irgendwas anderes im marketplace kann
man ja einen schmerzpreis verkaufen wie ist ein preis naja komm scheiß drauf was das
hebe mal auf weil ich einfach so man das braucht drücke lehrtaste wird das echt ist lehrtaste
konfirm ach so man ist lehrtaste für regisse ach so ah cool nice wusste ich nicht das ist
gut wobei ich ja mittlerweile schon den register flick drauf hab
so jetzt schweißen in wald ja passt eigentlich habe ich hier noch platz hab ich mein wald
ja auch komplett voll gekleistert mit irgendeinem mist war natürlich klar warum habe ich hier
450 karotten drinne wachs warum ich weiß auch nicht so genau oh ich muss mal auf den
bersi umlocken meine werker meine werker kurz mit spier versorgen ja ja wie viele joshies
haben wir hier eigentlich wir fallen jetzt wir fallen jetzt irgendwie drei vier verschiedene
joshies auf joshies mit sch joshi mit sh joshi mit einer anderen zahl hinten dran wir haben
ganz schön viele joshies aber ich spiele mann ich habe noch ein bisschen was vom brötchen
zu fordern kurz mit wo habe ich schon noch storage platz hier oben da wirst du eh gleich
hin legen wir den ganzen krempel dann da rein
also gehen wir erstmal quest ab dann reiten wir hoch legen den ganzen krempel in wald
rein wobei wir haben eigentlich geht eigentlich haben wir jetzt mal genug platz können wir
jetzt erstmal center all daily machen ja das passt so center all daily ist das doch hier
unten irgendwo oder ist basi hier müsste das irgendwo sein gucken wo gibt es denn die
center all daily wahrscheinlich hier irgendwo da oben muss ich gleich mal gucken oder hier
hier wahrscheinlich mal schauen finden wir gleich max warst du noch nicht pen doch also
ich war schon im bett sagen wir mal so also wirklich viel gepennt habe ich aber nicht
da reiten wir mal ein bisschen schneller
ich bräuchte mal ein schnelleres pferd
das beste ist nächste woche kann ich mir wahrscheinlich schon mal eine dande holen also wenn das ungefähr
wieder so ist wie hier oder nähe nähe übernächste woche das pack siegel brauche ich noch mal
dann habe ich 70 seals und dann sind wir wirklich komplett ausgerüstet
haben wir wirklich jeden scheiß mittlerweile den man so braucht an boss items erstmal schmuck
aus und vor aber ansonsten haben wir alles sogar die helme haben wir auch schon sache
immer best ausgerüsteter bdo noob aller zeiten hast du noch kontakt mit key der junge
ne schon ewig näher ewig nicht mehr nichts mehr gehört auf dem fast so so wir müssen
hier hoch oder hier hoch muss ich weiß bis heute nicht was der offizielle weg ist da
hoch zu kommen ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es dass es so gedacht ist dass man hier
hoch geht aber ich meine funktioniert na ich war wahrscheinlich irgendwo hier außen rum
laufen oder so contribution points kann ich nie genug haben so jetzt werden basis äh
nicht basis send towers gebashed send towers gebashed
sein tower bash ist real die müssen wir noch vorher bashen die gucken so als wollen sie
gebashed werden so reiten wir um die ecke da müssen wir mal gucken wo ist die wo ist
die center und daily gibt glaubt ihr habe ich schon nie gemacht sollte man einfach alle
notes connecten wo man vorbeikommt oder macht schon sinn die speziell zu verbinden du hast
gar nicht genug punkte um alles zu connecten also es ist schon sinnvoll sich die besten
notes rauszusuchen also das einzige note also denn man kann das hier quasi als komplett
eigenes spiel spielen dieses note system und da quasi unendlich optimieren also eines
der notes die glaube ich von allen so als mit am besten angesehen werden ist das hier
unten das da und dann halt auch dieses hier da muss man erst eine quest für machen dass
man das kriegt lindsch farm ruins da gibt es hier dieses trace of savagery savagery und
anderes zeug und das ist wohl eines der geilsten notes aber alle notes verbinden hast du gar
nicht genug punkte für ein hero lp so früh schon und naja erstens heute letzter tag urlaub
wo ich mich ablenken sonst denke ich da die ganze zeit daran dass ich morgen wieder früh
auf den muss und auf die arbeit gar kein bock drauf da außerdem ich muss eh ein bisschen
progres machen was hat er ja ist das vielleicht die sentauer daily lizards naja das ist nicht
die sentauer daily ich glaube da unten ist die sentauer daily oder oder auf bash wenn
nicht muss ich jetzt mal im internet gucken weiß einer wo das sentauer daily quest typ
ist vermute mal der hier ist es also ja ja da ist es wie kann man nicht hoch ah fährt
der gaul aber ich glaube hier sind auch keine mobs hier sind auch keine mobs hier kann es
auch stehen lassen so gift daily pls no mercy ja das ups no mercy denke ich für overwatch
auch immer keine motto die motto muss weg da war sentauer main bashen sentauer links
baschen sentauer alles sendauer basch jetzt der sentauer basch lasst mal mal hier stehen
das müssten jetzt 2 oder 3 also die 3 quests und danach gibt es wahrscheinlich noch eine
große kill quest also wir werden jetzt wahrscheinlich ein paar minuten damit zubringen sentowers
zu grinden und wahrscheinlich bei meinem rng glück gibt es dann gleich gürtel easy clap
was sind das hier sind das hier die miniatur sentowers zumal es ja gar nichts ne ist wieder
so geil bdo hier oben sind die doch in diesem tal drin so wie der bdo questmarker genau
wieder komplett fail ach ich glaube das war der sentower spot hier neben den sie mal ausgetauscht
haben weil die noobs immer verreckt sind als sie nach zum bazaar hoch geritten sind also
Leute die noch mehr noobs haben sich gedacht machen wir mal mini sentauren hin ich hab
das gefühl es gibt irgendwo also nicht öffentlich für uns zugänglich so eine sound datenbank
die alle mmos verwenden habt ihr nicht auch manchmal das gefühl das ist dass das ganz
viele sounds in gefühlt jedem mmo verwendet werden also gefühlt hat fast jedes mmo was
ich gespielt habe bei mobs sounds immer total viel ähnliches zeug
vor allem die sterbe sounds von den mobs das ist immer alles gleich in jedem mmo irgendwie
das rumgeschrei hier jetzt kommt mir nicht bekannt vor am besten ist da war ne von irgendeinem
dark entwickler der hat ein paar jahre später paar jahrzehnte später lange später nachdem
er mit dem game schon gar nichts mehr zu tun hat wizard wizard komm jetzt oh mensch muss
jetzt mal kurz werchen als er mit dem game schon gar nichts mehr zu tun hat hat er mal
erzählt wie die ihre mobs sounds gemacht haben und das lustige ist die haben ihre mobs
sounds halt gar nicht wirklich für die mobs gemacht die haben sich ne ne cd gekauft damals
da muss ich überlegen das muss ja so 2000 rum gewesen sein wo die damit entwicklung
angefangen haben und die haben sich einfach eine cd gekauft also quasi sowas wie stock
fotos halt bloß als sounds so eine stock sounds cd keine ahnung haben sie sich irgendwie
gekauft und haben dann einfach sounds davon genommen die am ehesten gepasst haben für
ihre mobs deswegen hören sich die dark mobs sounds auch so richtig kacke an so jetzt können
wir quest abgeben quest abgeben und danach gibt es wahrscheinlich die fette kill quest
die sounds
überlegt gerade welche mmo's die schon alles gespielt haben was soll ich mal überlegen
lass mal überlegen was haben wir alles gespielt also dark klar jahrelang rift terra fine fantasy
14 hilt wars 2 tso soll ich mal was vergessen also ich hab schon sehr viele mmo's gespielt
vor allem noch nicht irgendwie muss ich sagen endgame technisch gefällt mir video am besten
halt vielleicht gerade weil es halt so keins von diesen klassischen great endgame zeugs
gibt wo ja wo ein bisschen stimmt wo hab ich ganz vergessen aber wo haben wir aber nicht
also farbian gar nicht ich hab mit dem cast mit dem mastercrubber haben wir wo gespielt
hab ich damals wo gespielt ich hab wo ein bisschen auf dem letzten fliehschad den großen
fliehschad den es da gegeben hat gespielt als orc charmane bis irgendwie 25 oder so
dann wird der server geschlossen ganz toll wie ist denn der noch mal nostalrius genau
ich renn wieder hin das war ein geiler server was haltet ihr eigentlich von blizzards idee
selbst wo classic server anzubieten ich hab irgendwie die das gefühl das wird sehr halbherzig
sein
ich hab in blizzards so weit bis fast das vertrauen verloren dass sie nicht mehr genau
wissen was ihre spieler eigentlich wollen also jetzt nicht bavou bei vielen games guckt
euch mal diablo 3 an das war überhaupt nicht das was spieler wollten starcraft hat sich
auch in eine richtung entwickelt wo jetzt schon ganze liegen dicht gemacht wurden overwatch
sind auch viele sachen wo ich mir denke but why jeff warum die sind wo jetzt ist weiß
ich nicht das einzige wo blizzard wohl ganz gutes hämmchen zur zeit alles heroes of the
storm wenn man also den post glaubt dass die leute mit zufrieden sind wir sollen schatzkisten
baschen easy mal gucken wo schatzkisten sind wahrscheinlich nicht dort wo bdo quest marker
sind weil eins haben wir ja letzten tagen gelernt bdo quest marker sind ziemlich fail
sag ich mein pet
aber wo sind hier schatzkisten bestimmt hier oben bestimmt hier gehen wir mal da hoch
aber wir basteln unterwegs zentrauren weil vielleicht gibt es den gürteltrop machen
damage den mobs los warum machen die damage da muss ich ja tatsächlich mal mehr als
drei spells drücken um mich ab und zu nochmal selbst heilen das ist ja was hier nein so
kommen wir da nicht hoch aber hier kann man bestimmt irgendwie hochklettern bdo bdo kann
man überall irgendwie hochklettern genau sieht zwar nicht so aus als könnte man da hochklettern
aber da kann man hochklettern hier kann man nicht hochklettern ok easy da kommt man bestimmt
hoch da kommt man garantiert hoch guckts guckts bdo da kommt man kommt überall hoch easy pass
auf pass auf pass auf jetzt kommts bam fuck nein nein nein wizard ok ich muss doch außen
rumlaufen ne hier gehts hoch hier gehts hoch guck das sieht schon so aus jetzt haben sie
schon extra so gemacht dass man hier hochklettern kann oder auch nicht fuck kann man hier echt
nicht hochklettern oh das ist aber dumm muss ich jetzt echt außen rumlaufen naja gut lauf
ich halt außen rum zwar ist jetzt auch kein beinbruch wir sind ja schon quasi fast oben
so hier waren irgendwo schatzkisten kann ich noch dran erinnern haben wir mal gemacht
ja mit dem bersi ach ne hier waren die totems egal die sind auch irgendwo schatzkisten gewesen
haben mit dem bersi damals gemacht schon die quests glaube ich hab wieder das falsche buff
foot genommen immer das falsche buff foot hier oben gibt es doch bestimmt auch noch
was außer centaurs zum daschen was hat es mit der katze und linksaufsicht die verdeckt
den chat die verdeckt den ingame chat weil es nicht alle so geil finden dass man die
gilded chat quasi im stream sieht aber ich muss natürlich den chat sehen also das deswegen
ist die katze da unten außen ist die katze auch super hintergrund für twitch chat und
das ist schon sehr dramatisches bild von der katze muss man die guckt da schon so dramatisch
irgendwie wo sind noch schatzkisten das ist auch bdo wegfindung man kann einfach hier
runtergehen ok ich glaube wir müssen einfach ein bisschen rumrennen für schatzkisten und
centaurspecial dabei ist da kein ding questmarker sind wahrscheinlich irgendwie der bdo style
nur grobe hinweise drauf wo was ist das heißt am besten ist wir rennen einfach rum und
basten monster zu früh schon an er guck da ist was zum basten die mobs sehen halt auch
gefährlicher aus als sie sind und eine schatzkiste jawoll hier sind wir richtig samas samas completed
ja twitch mason wünscht ihr auch easy clap 2k18 jetzt werden die leute langsam wach
und war das auch eine base quest nein das war keine base quest das war eine base quest
und danach gibt es wahrscheinlich noch eine kill quest irgendwie tute 530 das machen wir
dann auch noch haben wir irgendwie runter ohne zu verrecken braucht man für das spiel
skill kommt drauf an was du machen willst in dem game wenn du krasse pvp duelle machen
willst oder pvp one on one one versus mehrere was auch immer dann auf jeden fall es ist
nicht getan wie jetzt im kreis kreiden drei spells zu drücken im wizard für einfach level
monster kreiden jetzt nicht so wirklich viel kommt auch ein bisschen auf die klasse an
aber wenn du pvp was reißen willst dann auf jeden fall wizard komm spring hoch complete
ich will da eigentlich kein drank haben komplett müssen wir gleich wieder wegschmeißen mal
müll nur infol ok 100 centaurs easy das ist ja überhaupt kein ding da gehen wir nicht
da hin sondern gehen wir auf den bash rauf das sind nämlich die meisten centaurs gewesen
schon der erste der gebashed werden will aber hier ist ein bisschen wenig ne wir machen
das anders wir laufen hier hinten rum wir laufen hier hinten rum und dann den berg hoch
und dann haben wir locker dann haben wir locker 100 voll mein 100 ist jetzt ja nicht so wahnsinnig
viel roma country questions sind glaube ich 600 killen reißt du was pvp war es nein was
ich kann ich ich kann nubs am 1000 spot bashen das kann ich aber kann es sein dass wir gerade
gehostet wurden oder so habe ich was verpasst moment muss mal kurz gucken ne weil auf einmal
so viele leute da waren
die mini die mini zertauchen hier irgendwie geil warum gibt es sowas überhaupt mini zertauchen
mein wozu es sieht vollkommen auch von der vom größten verhältnis vollkommen fail aus
irgendwie mini zertauchen ich meine das sieht ja schon besser aus es sieht halt normal groß
aus und auch so als wäre das model dafür gedacht in dieser größe angezeigt zu werden
ist
Ich brauche ein bisschen mehr, ein bisschen mehr Mops her, auf uns kommt er, bye!
So, das ist ja ewig.
Mops sounds besser.
Bogeys Nerven.
Kommt mal her, kommt mal, kommt mal her, ja, auf, kommt ja auch mal her.
Dauert das so lange, wenn man da immer die Mops einzeln killt.
Alle herkommen.
Geile Sand Towers.
100, 100 ist überhaupt kein Ding als KillQuest. Jetzt zacke ich.
Ich freue mich echt schon drauf, wenn es in 14 Tagen dann die Bosswaffe gibt.
Eventuell habe ich ja mega Glück vorher noch und snipe mir noch eine aus dem Auktionshaus aus dem Marketplace, aber ich glaube es eher nicht.
Aber in 14 Tagen gibt es safe Bosswaffe, also Boss Awakening.
Da bin ich gespannt darauf, dass der Wizard dann noch mehr OP hat.
Mir fällt gerade ein, eigentlich wollte ich was essen.
Ich habe ja seit ich Stream angemacht habe ich was zu essen schon, ich habe zweimal ins Brötchen gebissen.
Nice, nice.
18 Stück.
Aber hiermit quasi schon fast alles.
So, ich überlege gerade was wir danach machen, wenn wir hier die Daily Crampel fertig haben.
Wo ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf habe, ist die Karma SurfQuest weiter zu machen.
Sinnloses rumgerenne.
Da cryen dich lieber irgendwelche Mops.
Aber wir killen dann einfach noch ein paar Basis danach.
Glück auf Welt.
Und kippe ein bisschen Kohle.
Und ist hier direkt um die Ecke.
5 Stück noch.
Ich bin so wach heute.
Easy Clap, fertig.
Der Sound von den Mops.
Ich glaube ich baste da noch ein paar Basis einfach.
Das ist nie verkehrt.
Übrigens kommt man, wir haben schon 1% zu 61%.
Also wenn man das ordentlich grinden würde.
Moment, brenne ich überhaupt hin.
Wenn man das ordentlich grinden würde, geht das sogar mittlerweile.
Wen61.
2019.
Skill Punkt, jawoll.
Noch mehr Daily, noch mehr Sand Towers.
300.
Das ist gut.
Also für mich ist es jetzt nicht schlecht.
Sand Towers halt auch für den Gürtel.
Und Loot und Zeugs und Geld.
Ich bin jetzt 60, ich brauche jetzt ein bisschen Kohle.
Und noch ein bisschen Gier und sonst was, als das Schmuck upgraden kann.
5% sind an einem Tag drin.
Ja kann ich wahrscheinlich sogar mehr oder?
Also je nachdem wie lang ein Tag ist.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn du 10 Stunden grindest mit XP Buffs.
Vor allem noch mit Wochenende XP Buff, XP Buch, Black Spirit XP Buff und alles Mögliche.
Kann ich mir vorstellen, sind auch mehr drin als übrigens wo wir gerade bei XP Buffs sind.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
XP schadet nicht, wobei ich hätte vielleicht besser Skill XP nehmen sollen.
Weil ich brauche ja noch 30 Skill Points.
Auf der anderen Seite, ich muss ja noch Quests machen, die geben mir auch Skill Points.
Der X-Man.
10 Stunden typisch No-Lie.
Ich frag mal den Fabian, für den sind 10 Stunden Video-Crime nix, dann wird der erst warm.
Komm mal alle her, sein Towers, alle herkommen.
Alle herkommen und sich baschen lassen.
Vorher waren wir besser als hier auf diesem Berg, wir sind ja kaum sein Towers.
Ja die Rewards müssen wir auch mal einsammeln.
Da hast du schon recht, da sind vor allem auch wieder Skill Punkte dabei.
Aber die Dinger gehen ja nicht weg, die stacken sich ja.
Jetzt haut er ab, hat er sich alles überlegt.
Ich habe keine Bock mehr.
Komm mal alle her, alle Send Towers herkommen.
Die lassen sich auch nicht Knockbacken oder so.
Oder Knockdown.
Deswegen Crime wahrscheinlich keiner gerne hier.
Alle herkommen.
Du bist richtig neidisch, warum? Weil ich so viele Loyalty-Punkte noch habe in Rewards.
Mit dem Tamer könnte man doppelt so viele Mobs ziehen.
Ich glaube, mit dem Tamer kannst du noch 8 pullen mit dem Pat und 8 mit dem Tamer.
Das Lustige ist, das könnte man mit dem Wizard eigentlich auch.
Mit dem Wizard kannst du einmal hier Leute mit dem Lava Feld pullen und nochmal 8 Stück so.
Das ist jetzt hier bei Send Towers ein bisschen schlecht zu zeigen.
Aber der Wizard hat irgendwie alles.
Da haben sie sich überlegt beim Design vom Wizard, wir nehmen einfach alle Klassen und geben sie einer.
Und dann kommt der Wizard raus.
Also alle Fähigkeiten von jeder Klasse machen wir Wizard.
Mit dem Lava Feld kannst du 8 pullen und als Wizard selbst kannst du 8 pullen.
Das sieht man jetzt hier schlecht bei den Send Towers.
Zu wenig Mobs da.
Du musst halt die Mobs killen, bevor das Lava Feld ausläuft.
Sonst werden sie uns D.A. kronen, falls das überhaupt ein Wort ist.
Und haben wieder volle Leben.
Lohnt es sich eine GTX 1080 Zoll, wenn man eine GTX 1060 hat?
Eigentlich müsstest du die Frage ja selbst beantworten können, wenn du was hast, was nicht ordentlich läuft mit der 1060.
Was du aber unbedingt spielen willst, dann lohnt sich das.
Wenn du jetzt allerdings sagst, ich habe Games die laufen, bisschen höhere Details wären nice, muss aber nicht sein.
Dann nicht.
Das ist halt schwierig zu sagen jetzt.
Das ist so wie die Frage, sollst du jetzt einen neuen PC kaufen?
Das ist immer schwierig.
Wenn du was machen willst, was nicht läuft, dann ja.
Oder wenn du bessere Quali willst, höhere Auflösung, mehr Anti-Alasing, mehr Multi-Sampling.
Was ich sag.
Falls du das jetzt auf BDO bezogen meinst, dann brauchst du das nicht.
BDO läuft da ohne Probleme mit der 1060.
Guck mal, ich meine, ich hab eine 1080 Ti, also ich hab insgesamt, ich würd mal sagen, somit das Beste, was man sich zur Zeit an Gaming-Equipment kaufen kann.
Besser geht's eigentlich nicht.
Höchstens noch eine zweite Grafikkarte.
8700K und eine 1080 Ti.
Und selbst bei mir kackt BDO in den Städten ab mit Frames.
Das ist einfach BDO.
Das ist halt so.
Da kann man auch nix dagegen machen.
Ich mein, man muss sich das mal überlegen.
BDO ist bei mir, ist auf der M2 SSD installiert.
Also sprich, du kriegst aktuell nichts, was schneller Sachen lädt.
8700K ohne 1080 Ti.
Also es geht im Prinzip nicht besser.
Und trotzdem hat BDO die übelsten Frameshops des Todes.
Vor allem, wenn du in der Stadt reitest.
Das ist halt BDO.
Also wenn du deswegen dir eine 1080 kaufen willst, bringt es das auch nicht.
Wo bin ich denn hier überhaupt jetzt?
Ja, no second plan, das wünsch ich dir auch.
Easy clap, 2K18.
Die sind ja ordentlich riesbaufend.
Die haben doch keinen Bock, die wollen einfach nur dastehen.
Hab ich gedacht, der Wizard ist so OP, da greifen wir erst gar nicht an.
Okay, sieht man es ganz gut, wie viele Mops gepult sind.
Und der hat wieder endark rot, weil das Lavafeld weg war.
Was?
Moment, warum habe ich das jetzt als Titel gekriegt?
Ich muss das Game beleidigen, Alter.
Das Game rollen.
Ich muss mir mal das Gear-Foto angucken, ob das überhaupt aktuell ist.
Äh, Moment.
Hä?
Valkorion, du hast doch das Gear-Kommando umgestellt.
Warum ist das Gear-Kommando jetzt wieder das alte?
Hä?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Wobei, nee, passt, ist das Richtige.
Das Einzige, was ich noch gemacht habe, ist hier meine Awakening-Waffe noch ein bisschen zu upgraden.
Ist doch das richtige Gear, was drinnen ist.
Ich müsste jetzt langsam echt mal ein Frühstück vortragen.
Ich würde mich doch mal kurz was abbeißen.
Damn.
Tja Leute, wenn ihr jetzt Kopfschmerzen habt, hättet ihr lieber mit uns gestern Abend Overwatch Pure Games gemacht und euch nicht besoffen.
Dann wäre es jetzt auch kein Problem, ne?
Aber so RL-Kacke da immer.
Also 2018 wird bei mir definitiv nicht das Jahres des RLs werden.
Und das liegt vor allem daran, als ich jetzt wieder mit BDO angefangen habe.
Aber aktuell macht es vieles Bock. Kann einfach sinnlos Mops baschen.
Moin Nibbles.
Energy. Haben sie gegift, die Centaurs.
Das ist doch auch wieder ein Entsatz. Die Centaurs haben Energie gegift, jawoll, perfekt.
Das Game ist viel zu kompliziert. Im Kreis laufen und drei Spells drücken gerade, was ich hier mache.
Ansonsten ist das Game gar nicht so kompliziert. Es gibt halt viele Sachen, die du machen kannst.
Die sind an sich für sich genommen, aber gar nicht so kompliziert.
Es gibt halt viel, deswegen muss man auch relativ viel lernen. Oder man lässt halt links liegen, wie ich, irgendwelche Life-Skill-Geschichten.
Aber es spricht für das Game, wenn es kompliziert ist.
Man kann ja nicht immer alles den MMOs komplett in den Arsch geschoben bekommen.
Das ist das, was mich bei vielen MMOs auch übelst nervt.
Gibt es später Fraktions-PvP in BDO? Es gibt es jetzt schon.
Es gibt es seit Release schon. Also Factions ist Gilde in dem Fall.
PvP ist eh ziemlich vielfältig. Also du kannst im Prinzip von Battlefield zu One-on-ones üben.
Du kannst in der Arena gehen, du kannst Gilde in Siege, Gilde in PvP machen.
Du kannst in der Wüste einen auf Bandit und ich kille alles machen.
Das ist generell auch an jeder Stelle zu jeder Zeit Open World PvP möglich.
Du warst anscheinend nicht besoffen genug, dass du das Game noch spielen konntest.
Wo mich wieder zu dem Punkt zurückbringt, so kompliziert kann BDO nicht sein,
wenn man es noch schafft, komplett besoffen sein Main zu schrotten.
So kompliziert kann es gar nicht sein, weil jemand macht das Game viel zu kompliziert.
Ok, jetzt sieht man es wieder, dass das Lava fällt mehr als 8 Mobs pullt.
Also der Wizard pullt 8, das Lava fällt pullt 8.
Vengeance ist Wizard beste.
8 Mobs noch.
Komm mal alle her hier, Sand Towers.
Alle her komm.
Sand Towers, please.
Come on.
Come on, Prue.
Reku.
Resparen.
Auf jetzt, Sand Towers, movet euch mal.
Hier sind ordentlich viele, komm mal alle her.
Alle her komm, alle gebashed werden.
Easy bash, easy life.
Letztens hat irgendjemand geschrieben, er hat seinen Sarkast Def, also nicht auf Trier,
irgendjemand hat letztens geschrieben, er hat seinen Sarkast Def preordert für irgendwie
40 Mille oder so, echt schon schlechtes.
Die Mob Sounds.
Wizard, nein so geht das nicht.
Shrecked.
So wir können eigentlich schon mal zurück Richtung Questgeber gehen.
Weil die 10 kriegen wir auf dem Weg auch.
Kommt mal her, Sand Towers, auf jetzt, dass es mal ein bisschen schneller geht.
Aber es kann ja nichts.
Hier ist ein Stück noch, der da, der da, der da, ach hier sind so viele, easy.
Schafft.
So, jetzt müssen wir bloß noch überlegen, was wir als nächstes machen.
Ich esse mein Brötchen jetzt erstmal, weil ich das schon seit 4 Stunden machen will.
Oder 3 Stunden, oder keine Ahnung, eineinhalb Stunden, solange bin ich hier noch gar nicht
on, dann bin ich schon on, ich glaube 2 Stunden.
Sand Tower bash, easy, easy clap, ja ja 2018 wird alles easy clap.
Alles easy clap 2018.
Nicht mal alleine da hochlaufen kann er.
Ein nice Autorun, ja.
Der war top, ne.
Ich kann jetzt wenigstens kurz was futtern hier, aber nicht, weil das kriegt der Hinterwizard
alleine.
Hey, Daily erledigt.
Ist Witch und Wizard?
Naja, also ist schon ziemlich ähnlich.
Und vor Awakening konnte man quasi sagen, Witch ist so weiblicher Wizard.
Aber die spells sind jetzt ein bisschen anders.
Alles in allem kann man eigentlich sagen, Wizard ist besser.
Vor allem wenn es um PvP one on ones und sowas noch irgendwie mitgeht.
Ne, wir wollten jetzt hoch reiten zum Bazaar und das Zeug in den Baul pflegen.
So, was mache ich jetzt ohne Waffe mit meinem Ranger?
Tja.
Das ist schwierig da.
So, ich mache jetzt Autorun zum Bazaar, Autoride und esse jetzt endlich vor meinem Brötchen
fertig.
Level 51, ich kenne mich mit Low Level Spots nicht aus.
Dreimal dürft ihr raten wer mich gezogen hat bis 55 damals.
Aber Catfish Spots war früher ganz nice, Low Level für Geld und Act.
Legg Dazzard, wo am besten kaufen Steam oder Webseite?
Ich weiß nicht was es für Packs auf Steam gibt, aber das Pack auf der BDO Seite von den
Items lohnt sich.
Also dieses Pack mit Pferdeflöte und Value Packs und sowas drinne, wenn man das Spiel
halt ernsthaft spielen will.
Ansonsten kann man sich auch mal erstmal die Testversion angucken, kostet gar nichts.
Reinst du eins die gleichen?
Keine Ahnung, dann ist es egal.
Dann ob du es lieber in deiner Speedbibliothek stehen haben willst oder nicht.
Weil im Prinzip macht es auch von den Surfern kaum einen Unterschied.
Du darfst auf Einsteigersurfern oder EXP-Surfern anfangen mit der Standalone Version und mit
der Steam Version darfst du auf Steam Einsteigersurfern anfangen.
Also eigentlich ist es egal.
Ich weiß auch nicht auf welchen, wir können mal gucken auf welchen Server mehr los ist.
Das sind die Steam Server, ok es ist nirgendwo was los, aber gut es ist erster.
Doch guck mal, auf dem normalen Standalone Einsteigerserver bzw. Wiedereinsteigerserver
ist mehr los als auf den Steam Server.
Also vielleicht spricht das ja für Standalone.
Hast du durchgestreamt?
Ne ne hab ich nicht.
Ich hab nicht durchgestreamt.
Ich war pennen so ab 2 haben wir Schluss gemacht glaube ich, aber ich hab nicht so wirklich
viel gepennt.
Man kann die Server so wechseln, ja kannst du.
Du kannst auf diese Einsteigerserver auch nur, ich überleg gerade, wie lang kann man da
drauf?
Steht nicht nah.
Also mein XP Bonus gibt es auf beiden Einsteigerserver.
Ich glaube in einem Monat, ich glaube in einem Monat kann man auf diese Einsteigerserver
drauf.
Steht doch hier irgendwie.
Server ist prepared blablabla, mehr XP.
Man kann bis 58,5 werden auf den Servern.
Man kann jederzeit auch auf andere Server wechseln, wenn man das lieber ist.
Genau 30 Tage.
30 Tage, wenn man neu ist in dem Game oder 30 Tage, wenn man eine Weile nicht gespielt
hat.
Was ist das eigentlich, warum kann ich das nicht verkaufen?
Was ist das?
Ah, in-camera-self Zeug, ok.
Das behalten wir mal, das wiegt nicht viel.
So, noch was zum Sellen, den Krempel.
So, das wars.
Das kommt in Wald.
Da müssen wir noch mal ganze Kohle wieder nach Velia transportieren.
Da machen wir einen Altinova noch, 50 Millionen rumliegen.
PVP ist quasi immer an oder gibt es einen extra Server?
Beides.
Also PVP ist immer an.
Allerdings kann man nicht einfach ungeschraft random permanent Leute bashen.
Was, wenn du hier in dein Charakterprofil rein guckst, hast du hier Karma-Punkte und je
nachdem, wie gut der Gegner ausgerüstet ist, den du killst, verlierst du weniger, wenn du
einen PK hast.
Um Leute zu PK an, musst du halt PK anmachen, gibt es einen Knopf für, dann kannst du
ihn killen und je nachdem, wie gut der ausgerüstet ist oder wie schlecht, verlierst du mehr oder
weniger Punkte.
Also wenn du jetzt den übelsten Noob weg bashst, verlierst du halt mehr und wenn du
bei Null bist beziehungsweise Minus, dann wirst du angreifbar quasi permanent für den
kompletten Server.
Und wenn du dann stirbst, hast du auch noch ein bisschen mehr Nachteile, dass du zum Beispiel
eine Chance drauf hast, dass auch beim PVP-Tod, du Kristalle aus deinen Items verlierst und
sowas.
Also so ganz ungestraft, alles weg PVP'n kann man nicht, außer, aber wie gesagt,
Open-World-Gebiet war, außer in der Wüste hier.
Das ist ja so als High-Level-Gebiet gedacht hier, die Wüste.
In der Wüste kannst du PVP'n, soviel du lustig bist im Endeffekt.
Aber du verlierst immer noch, immer noch Punkte.
Aber du, also du hast sonst keine großartigen Probleme, wenn du dann stirbst, wirst du hier
im...
Wo ist denn das Gefängnis eigentlich?
Ich war da noch nie drinne, hier irgendwo.
Gibt's ein Gefängnis, dann musst du da wieder quasi fliehen danach.
So und was es gibt, es gibt extra, war ich aber auch noch nie drauf, hat der Fabian erzählt,
es gibt jetzt mittlerweile extra PVP-Channels.
Dort ist PVP immer an für alle, die drauf sind und du verlierst auch keine Karma-Punkte,
wenn du Leute killst.
Da ist schon ein Inventar wieder frei.
Was ich mich frage ist, ob es auf dem PVP-Channel irgendwie auch mehr XP gibt oder sowas.
Oder ob man das einfach nur macht zum besser Bashen.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, viele Spots sind auf dem PVP-Channel frei, weil viele Leute
halt nicht Dauer-PVP anhaben wollen.
Wenn man wieder mit BDO anfangen will, lohnt sich das, wenn dir das Spiel Spaß gemacht
hat.
Also dann weißt du, wenn du wieder anfängst, weißt du ja schon, wie das Game im Prinzip
ist.
Man kann in der Wüste negativ gehen, ohne was zu verlieren, soweit ich weiß schon.
Also in der Wüste hast du keine negativen Konsequenzen, wenn du stirbst.
Du wirst halt ins Gefängnis geworfen hier unten.
Unten ist das irgendwo.
Und das hier ist auch eine extra Stadt, wo Leute mit negativ Karma hin können, weil
sonst wirst du ja angegriffen von Wachen.
So, jetzt wollte ich mal kurz überlegen, was wir machen.
Also wir grinden auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen sinnlos rum.
Wir reiten jetzt erstmal wieder Basis.
Basis ist ganz guter Ausgangspunkt.
Basis ist ganz guter Ausgangspunkt, das ist genau in der Mitte.
Waschen wir noch ein paar Basis.
Vielleicht haben wir ja Klücken kriegen, Gürtel.
Der Patrick hat Übels Klücken gehabt, die letzten paar Tage haben wir vier Basi Bells
oder so getroffen.
Krasser Shit.
Anirksa Chava 35.
Also was man da wissen muss ist, Leveln geht jetzt viel schneller als früher.
Seit ein paar Patches.
Seit ein paar Patches ist Leveln viel schneller.
Also sogar bis 60.
Ja, man kann BDO schon, das finde ich auch gut an BDO.
Man kann BDO auf der einen Seite 24-7 spielen, wenn man so der ultra-hardcore BDO-Kreiner-Spieler
ist.
Man kann BDO aber auch relativ entspannt casual spielen.
Also sie geben sich da Mühe, dass du als Casual-Spieler nicht total den Anschluss verlierst
und ganz gut mithalten kannst, aber du trotzdem Vorteile hast, wenn du 24-7 spielst.
Das muss auch sein.
Max, wann wirst du mal, wann ich mir ein neues Pferd kaufe?
Wir können gleich mal bei irgendeinem Stable gucken, was es gibt.
Aber ich meine scheiß drauf.
Wurscht.
Ich müsste höchstens mal wieder mal meine...
Wie macht man eigentlich das Pferde-Pop-Up auf?
Wie macht man nochmal das Pferde-Ausrüstung auf?
Keine Ahnung, muss ich mal gucken.
Das war alles für einen Shortcut, das hatte irgendwie so ein blödes...
Ich muss nämlich mal hier Zeug reparieren vom Pferd.
Welche Version von BDO hast du eigentlich?
Die mit der Pferdeflöte drinne.
Mit der Pferdeflöte und den Value Packs.
Da gibt es glaube ich nur eine.
F5 bis F7, ich meine nicht das Pferdeinventar, sondern das Pferde-Equipment.
Geht das auch hier mit?
Nee.
Ups.
Das Pferde-Equipment, geht das auch hier mit auf?
Ah, F7, F7.
Ja, genau, Equipment.
Reparieren wir mal Equipment.
Wo ist der nächste Stable?
Gehen wir mal zum nächsten Stable und reparieren das.
Wo sind wir überhaupt zum Stable?
Den zum Schmied muss man da wahrscheinlich.
Setz dich auf Pferd und drück P.
Ah, der ist ja noch besser.
Moment, wat?
Die haben doch da auch einen Repaer-Dude oben drinne.
Die haben doch garantiert hier einen Repaer-Typ drinne.
Max, wie lange hast du für die Charaktererstellung gebraucht?
40 Minuten, 45 Minuten oder so?
Ich hab den Wizard ja als allererster Charakter erstellt nie gespielt.
Damals, als ich das Game angefangen hab.
So, und man konnte damals nur Wizards erstellen, die alt aussehen.
Also sprich, junger Wizard ging damals gar nicht.
Jetzt Reparieren jetzt.
Zum Repen muss das Pferd nur am Schmied stehen.
Nichts aus... Aha!
Das ist gut zu wissen.
Aber ich mein, so geht's ja auch.
Oh, ist das kaputt jetzt?
Kann ich das nicht mehr retten?
Oder wie ist das?
Kann man das nicht mehr retten, das Pferdezeug, wenn es einmal im Arsch ist?
Kann das sein?
Ach nee, ich hab nicht genug Geld.
Naaah.
Kann man eben noch ein bisschen was sellen hier.
Da, das willst du doch bestimmt haben.
Ich hab mal keine Kohle dabei.
Ja, dann muss mein Gaul eben erstmal so hier mit auskommen.
Weil ich mein, wir müssen hier eh nicht weit.
Wir wollen jetzt einfach dahin.
Das ist ja direkt um die Eck.
Danach haben wir auch genug Geld.
Also auf dem Pferd sitzt P.
Und dann kann man wahrscheinlich Inventar machen und den Kran wieder anziehen.
Okay.
So, und dann müssen wir, wenn wir das hier, wenn wir jetzt noch ein bisschen Basi gegrindet haben,
müssen wir unbedingt die Kohle von Basar und Altinova mal nach Velia bringen.
Ich hab hier in, wo hab ich die Kohle verteilt?
Hier haben wir, na auf, klick so.
Hier sind irgendwie 10 Millionen Coins drinne und in Altinova sind nochmal 55.
Okay, das heißt, dann haben wir da 260.
Das ist gut.
So ein bisschen, bisschen Kohle in Reserve ist nie verkehrt.
Da kann ich noch ein paar danne Snipes probieren.
Pferd, stell dich nicht so an.
Da ging es rein.
Ja, nicht genug Geld.
Ja, ich hab jetzt so sehr drauf geachtet, dass ich keinen Inventarplatz irgendwie mit Coins und so verschwende.
Und jetzt hat man es gebraucht.
Basi-Bash Beste.
Ja, Basi-Bash Beste.
Weil ansonsten sind wir mit den Dailys durch.
Ich hab die Gäste leider nicht abgegeben bei Catrees, sonst hätten wir das natürlich noch machen können.
Wie macht man sich sein Equip als Anfänger?
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich kann mich da nicht so richtig dran erinnern.
Außerdem hatte ich jemand dabei, der sich auskennt mit dem Game.
Ich geh mal davon aus.
Du grindest einfach und holst dir die ein oder anderen Quest-Items unterwegs.
So würd ich das mal vermuten.
Und bis 56 geht übelst schnell mittlerweile.
Also ich würd auch gar nicht so sehr den übelsten Quest grind machen, sondern wirklich Mob-Splash.
In BDO levelst du durch Mob-Splash, nicht durch Quests.
In XP kannst du, bringt es jetzt auch nicht.
Du musst dir einen guten Spot suchen, Mob-Splashen, easy.
Und mittlerweile ist es ja so OP alles.
Also du kannst auch auf der Main-Quest folgen eigentlich.
Da gibt es ja auch Appenzumer-Equip.
Was, ich hab irgendwas getroppt, hab ich grad nicht hingekriegt?
Ach so, Scrolls.
Dafür hab ich den ganzen Tag glaub ich noch keine gekriegt sonst. Bis jetzt.
Also ich hab mir ja ein paar neue Chars erstellt, einfach um sie für Failstacks zu verwenden.
Weil ich auf Level 14 hochgelevelt halte, das geht halt innerhalb von 2 Minuten gefühlt.
Wenn du hast das Start-Equipment, dann killst du Mops, die sind 8 Level über dir und du bist quasi instant Level 14.
Das geht mega schnell.
Das heißt, das ist wirklich mittlerweile ziemlich easy mit Leveln.
Zumindest bis 56 mit bis 58 auch. Danach geht es ein bisschen langsamer.
Aber kein tagelanges Gekrein mehr, wie das früher war. Die Belichtung sieht ja ein bisschen Fail aus gerade.
Also Frazier meinte mal, man kann quasi in einem Tag bis 59, im nächsten nach bis 60.
Das halte ich jetzt für ein bisschen sehr gewagt, aber sag mal so in 3 Tagen geht das.
Wenn du halt viel spielst. Ansonsten brauchst du halt 1-2 Wochen.
Wenn du nicht so viel spielst, wenn du am Tag nur 1-2 Stunden spielst oder war gar nicht und dann wieder 2 Stunden oder so.
Dann brauchst du halt mal eine Woche oder zwei bis 58-59. Aber das ist nichts im Vergleich zu früher.
Da war der Cryant quasi ab 58 mal nervig.
Da war sie, Basch.
Oh, jetzt sind die Leute aber wach.
Da haben wir auf die Zuschauerzahl geguckt, 104.
Auch das ist natürlich auch ein guter Tipp, du kannst dir Guides angucken.
Also bei BDO sich Guides anzugucken ist das Beste, was man machen kann.
Also man sollte sich auf jeden Fall einen Enchanting Guide angucken und auch so eine Node Guide.
Oder man hat hier jemanden, der sich mit dem Game auskennt. Das ist natürlich auch enorm praktisch.
Man kann sich ja mittlerweile sogar Ausrüstung für Contribution Points leihen, die ganz gut ist.
Und wenn du die Ausrüstung leihst, kannst du später die Awakening Quest machen, dann leihst du dir noch ordentliche Ausrüstung, ordentliche Waffen für Contribution Points.
Da kannst du dann direkt Helms bashen oder sowas für wieder dick Exp Kohle und Schmuck-Drops.
Also ich glaube, das ist ganz gute Progression, auch wenn du, wie gesagt, auch wenn ich selbst ein ziemlicher Noob in dem Game bin, ich glaube so als Progression ist ganz gut.
Wenn du dann einfach nachdem du Awakening Quests machen kannst, dann mietest du dir eine Waffe für Contribution Points.
Man bekommt mittlerweile über die Black Spirits Quest auch ganz gute Rüstung und sowas.
Und dann machst du Helms und... Moment, ich muss gleich mal auf die Map gucken.
Dann machst du Helms und Elricks Shrine und hier unten an der Mine. Das geht alles, guck mal die Mine geht mit 70-90 AP.
Und hier oben der Krampel geht dann mit 90-110-95-150. Also das geht. Das kriegt man zusammen.
Und dann habt ihr dann auch den Drop-Schmuck von den Mobs. Der ist halt echt gut.
Vor allem, wenn man zum fünfer Set anzieht, dieses Sula-Dings-Schmuck-Set, sieht man ja, was das gibt.
Du kriegst 300 HP plus 20 Akku dabei und die Drops sind nicht schwer zu bekommen.
Da basht man mal jeweils 1-2 Stunden an den jeweiligen Spots oder mit Pech 3-4 Stunden an den jeweiligen Spots, dann hat man das.
Wie hast du das auf der Karte auf AP geschaltet? Das ist glaube ich immer so.
Das steht nicht bei allen Spots dabei. Das ist glaube ich immer so. Ich habe da nichts eingeschaltet.
Meine Basi-Rotation ist ziemlich der Crap.
Ich glaube, welches Buff-Food ist jetzt wieder dran? AP, AP, Attack-Speed, das da ist dran.
Das steht auch nicht bei allen Spots dran. Das steht so quasi nur bei den Top-Spots dran.
Im neuen Gebiet soll es angeblich super Low-Level-Spots geben.
Also hier unten soll es angeblich super Low-Level-Spots geben.
Also das hier nicht. Das sind die High-Level-Spots. Aber hier in diesem Gebiet soll es mega gute Low-Level-Spots geben.
Die APs stehen nicht bei allen Spots dran. Ich glaube nur bei welchen, wo die Entwickler gedacht haben, die sind gut.
Oder die besuchtesten Spots.
So und wenn du dann einen Schmuck zusammen hast und die Quests gemacht hast, dann kannst du im Zweifelsfall, wenn dir sonst nichts bei einfällt, gehst du hier zu Hause und bashen.
Das ist so der beliebteste Spot überhaupt. Da ist immer voll und immer was los.
Zum größten Teil auch Gruppe, das heißt dann macht es auch nicht so viel aus, wenn du jetzt nicht das Top-Gear hast.
Auch Wizard, komm on.
Hat jemand von euch in letzter Zeit mal einen neuen Account gemacht und bis 56 levelt? Also quasi komplett ohne schon bestehende Items rüberzumulen?
Falls ja, wie lange habt ihr dafür gebraucht?
Also ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn man sich auskennt in dem Game geht es auch mit einem neuen Account innerhalb von 1-2 Tagen. Aber wenn man sich die meisten Leute diesen neuen Account machen,
müssen sie sich natürlich auch erstmal in BDO ein bisschen reinfinden.
Also ich denke mal, wenn man mal mit einer Woche rechnet, die man braucht bis 56, wo man dann quasi Awakening machen kann und das müsste eigentlich ganz gut hinhauen.
Wenn man noch ein paar Guides guckt und es gibt ja auch irgendwelche Progression Guides und das geht.
Also wenn man richtig hardcore ist, kriegt man es wahrscheinlich auch, wenn man neu in dem Game ist in 3 Tagen hin oder 4.
Ich gerate ich jetzt einfach mal so.
Suche gerade eine Stelle, wo ich 51, 52, 53 machen kann. Also das einzige Low Level Spot, wo ich mich noch dran erinnern kann, der ganz gut gewesen ist.
Ich hab halt genau 2 Chars hier in dem Game. War hier unten der. Moment.
Hier. Der da.
Catfish Camp. Das war angesagt früher oder hier neben dran.
Das da. Mancher Forest und Catfish Camp war das, was ich mitgekriegt habe damals, was angesagt war für Low Level Spots für Expo und Geld.
Wie gesagt, da habe ich keine Ahnung von.
Shit, wenn man ins Bett geht, ist Max online. Wenn ich aufstehe ist Max online.
Max, bist du immer online jetzt?
Das ist so Trigger Frage, weil ich habe heute den letzten Tag Urlaub und ich muss morgen wieder arbeiten gehen. Ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock.
So wirklich überhaupt keinen Bock. Ich weiß, wenn ich morgen auf der Arbeit bin, ist das alles nicht so wild.
Dann ist das eigentlich ganz okay wieder. Aber so der Tag, bevor ich auf die Arbeit wieder gehe, habe ich so keinen Bock, so keinen Bock.
Das ist schlimmer als letzter Ferientag, wo man wieder in die Schule musste. Wobei, nee, nee, nee, nee, ist nicht schlimmer.
Stream von der Arbeit. Wir haben uns ja schon mal überlegt, ob wir nicht SysAdmin TV machen sollen.
Aber da hatte die Firma was dagegen.
Läuft das Stream wieder oder immer noch? Da läuft wieder. Ich war auch pennt zwischendurch. Ich habe aber nicht viel gepennt.
Keine Basi. Wird er geflasht.
Übrigens, ich erzähle das jetzt seit zwei Stunden schon. Ich habe einen Frühstück, der aber noch nicht gefottert hat.
Das ist Schneckentempo.
Da war jetzt aber nichts, wo ich mein Spell hingesetzt habe.
Bin wieder eingestiegen vor von 30 auf 4 bis 5 Tage. Was?
Auf 56. Ah, okay. Ja, das geht. Das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Wenn man sich mit dem Game beschäftigt, geht das garantiert. Geht das? Geht das? Gut.
Und selbst wenn man es nicht so schnell hinkriegt, ist ja auch kein Ding. Weil man hat ja auch nichts davon.
Wenn man das übelst rushed, im Endeffekt nichts von der Gamewelt und so mitbekommt.
Was ist eigentlich eine gute Basi-Rotation? Ich habe das Gefühl, meine Rotation ist mega crap. Ist schlecht hin.
Böse Crap-Rotation.
Ja, weil ich sagen wollte, es hat ja auch keinen Sinn, wenn man nichts mitbekommt von der Spielwelt und überhaupt keine Ahnung hat, was in dem Game eigentlich abgeht.
Das heißt, wenn man neu ist, ist ja auch nicht schlimm, wenn man irgendwie 2-3 Wochen dann da rum macht bis 56 oder mehr.
Und sich einfach ein bisschen mit dem Spiel beschäftigt. Geil zuguckt.
Krypto-Ka habe ich noch gar nicht aufgemacht.
So, und eine Sache, bevor ich sie vergesse, weil ich vergesse sie garantiert wieder.
Ich muss jetzt mal meine Rewards einsammeln.
108xLoyalty Points. 108, Leute. 108.
Professional Cock.
Aber es ist nice, hier gibt es Skill-Punkte.
Jetzt habe ich hier noch alles offen.
Ist das richtig? Ich habe noch eine Chest.
Gucken wir noch gleich mal rein.
Also wir haben die Auswahl, entweder das Ding zu verkaufen oder aufzumachen.
Was ist denn da drin alles?
Im Prinzip fast alles besser, als sie zu verkaufen.
So, Leute. Chat. Ich brauche Energie. Ich brauche Energie. Please give energy. Wir brauchen gute Drops.
Fenris Blue. Ich wüsste nicht, was ich einem anderen Bot beibringen sollte, als das, was der Nightbot schon kann.
Leute, ihr müsst mir Energie geben. Wenn ich Energie kriege über den Chat, dann mache ich die Kiste auf.
Was? Du brauchst einen Golden Key?
Okay. Ich habe das Event voll verpennt.
Hier. Okay. Es wird Energie gegiftet. Dann machen wir das jetzt mal auf.
Okay. Auf geht's.
Was war jetzt drinne?
Hä? Was war jetzt drinne?
Was war denn jetzt drinne?
Hat irgendjemand gecheckt, was jetzt drinne war?
Ah. Ancient Guardians. Naja, hat sich doch schon mal gelohnt, anstatt 4 Millionen für die Kiste.
Das Ding. Ich meine, was anderes wäre besser gewesen. Aber ich meine, immerhin, ja.
Schau mal, besser als 3 Millionen für die Kiste.
Da sieht man aber, wie inkonsistent das ist. Normalerweise zeigt BDO neue Sachen im Inventar immer klitzert an, aber da jetzt nicht.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch für Rewards?
Gucken wir mal. Die sammel ich jetzt nicht ein. Da bin ich wahrscheinlich komplett überladen. Allein schon von den Flaschen oder so.
Cooking-Skill-Exp. Fishing-Skill-Exp. Cooking-Skill-Exp. Ich brauch Combat-Exp. Combat-Exp brauch ich. Fishing-Exp. Training-Exp.
Oh Mann. Kack-Mob.
Training-Exp. Combat-Skill-Points. Die klären wir jetzt.
Ich hab sogar noch die Rewards offen für Level 20.
Den sammeln wir jetzt mal ein, weil ich brauch Skill-Punkte.
Ach, ich muss da unten irgendwas auswählen. Was weiß ich? Bam.
Ist eh was Tolles. Nee.
Mal kurz den Level-20er-Rewards.
Weißt du?
1000 Spielstunden.
Das ist eigentlich total erblützend, sich einen eigenen Bot zu basteln.
Wie viele Rewards ich hab. Ich bin begeistert.
Dieses Event gibt's doch gar nicht mehr.
Den Park gibt's schon gar nicht mehr.
Sammeln wir später ein. Halloween-Coin.
Was ich hier alles noch offen hab, ne? Events, alle schon ewig abgelaufen.
So, ich muss jetzt mal mein Fenster aufmachen.
Ich sitze hier nämlich seit irgendwie um 10 da. Ich hab extra den Rollo runtergelassen, weil mir's zu hell war.
Ich muss jetzt mal aufmachen, sonst schlaf ich echt da ein.
Was motiviert dich dieses Spiel zu spielen? Zum ersten, ich hoffe man hört mich. Zum ersten, dass ich mit dem Fabian was spielen kann, weil wir suchen da schon lange den MMO, wo wir da was zusammenspielen können.
Zum zweiten natürlich sein Held verbessern.
Hat man das erste gehört, was ich gesagt hab?
Einfach weil es für den MMO ist, was ich mal mit dem Frasher zusammen spielen kann. Wo wir schon lange nach dem Game gucken, was wir zu zweit spielen können.
Und halt Held verbessern. So, was hat eigentlich bei den meisten MMOs motiviert?
Wie lange hast du für dein Equip gebraucht? Ich kann's dir nicht genau sagen, weil das war mein AFK-Fischheld davor.
Also ich hab jetzt auf dem Profil 31 Tage, das ist halt auch nicht viel. Aber das war halt auch mein AFK-Fischer.
Also ich hab mega reingelackt, was Gear betrifft. Also extrem. Ich glaub es gibt nicht viele, die so extrem reingelackt haben, was Gear anbelangt.
Also im Endeffekt, ich hab's ja schon ein paar mal erzählt, Jais Helm liegt in Velia rum. Also Jais Helm gesniped aus dem Marketplace.
Die Tree Spirit Armor aus einer Reward-Kiste, das Ding selbst gecraftet.
In der zweiten Woche, als ich das Game gespielt hab, lucky aus dem Weekly Quest Reward gezogen.
Und ich wusste damals überhaupt nicht zu schätzen, wie selten das Zeug ist.
Und im Januar, also nein, was heißt im Januar, jetzt, also diesen Monat, in 14 Tagen gibt's da noch Dande Awakening Waffe.
Und dann bin ich fertig. Da brauchst du nur noch Schmuck.
Also die ist safe, die Dande. Die gibt's definitiv in ungefähr 14 Tagen, weil ich hab genug Siegel gesammelt.
Ich hab jetzt 65 Siegel und 70 brauch man.
Was machst du, wenn du alles hast? Ja, das weiter verbessern. Das ist ja grad das Geile an dem Progression System. Du hast halt nicht wie in anderen, also was heißt das Geile?
Es hat seine Vornachteil, ja, muss man auch dazu sagen.
In anderen, ein bisschen, also in anderen Loot-basierten Spielen oder anderen MMOs ist es halt so, du hast halt für jeden, für jede Charakterklasse, für jeden Slot hast du halt immer Best-of-Slot-Items oder halt total viele zur Auswahl.
Je nachdem, wie das MMO gedacht ist, ja.
Aber hier ist es so, du hast halt zum größten Teil ist das hier bei den meisten Klassen gleich, was Rüstung anbelangt.
Also Schmuck und Offhand und so unterscheiden sich natürlich nach Klasse und Mainhand und sowas.
Aber was Rüstung anbelangt, ist bei den meisten Klassen das gleiche halt am besten, aber es bringt dir halt nichts, wenn du diese Rüstung hier hast.
Weil die Rüstung ist quasi in der Form, wie sie droppt, scheiße.
Und du musst sie halt upgraden.
Das heißt, das was hier den Progression ausmacht ist halt, dass du dann hier upgradest.
Du behältst halt das hier, du kriegst halt im Endeffekt keinen neuen Best-of-Slot-Drop, wie das in anderen MMOs ist, wo es da neuen Raid gibt und halt neue bessere Items.
Sondern du hast halt hier deine Items und kannst da upgraden.
Ab und zu gibt es auch mal neue Items, die sich lohnen.
Das Upgraden ist halt Vor- und Nachteil von BDO zugleich.
Weil es ist halt sehr random.
Es ist sehr random, allerdings, man kann es bis zu einem gewissen Grad optimieren, wenn man sich mit dem Enchanting-System auskennt.
Also dass man halt möglichst viele Versuche rausholt und die Chancen am besten versucht zu verwerten.
Ist der Maidstein Main? Ja.
Wizard ist mein Main.
Zug.
Das war mal ursprünglich mein Angelheld, als ich noch den Versi gespielt habe.
Aber seit ich wieder richtig BDO spiele, habe ich gesagt, komm scheiß auf Versi, ich mache mir jetzt einen OP-Wizard.
Und gut ist.
Das war auch der beste Wizard, das macht mir auch mehr Bock als Versi.
Versi ist viel zu skill-lastig, das geht nicht.
Ich will lieber drei Tasten drücken und alles ownen, das ist besser.
Wie sieht das mit PvP bei mir aus?
Ab und zu ein bisschen Open-World-PvP.
Ich habe jetzt nichts Organisiertes, geschweige denn, dass ich meine Klasse auch nur annähernd so gut spielen könnte, dass ich da was reißen würde.
Ich benutze ja noch nicht mal die meisten Spells.
Der Wizard hat so viele geile Spells, die ich nie benutze, weil man die zum Cri-Cri-Cripen nicht braucht.
Zum Beispiel du kannst Mops einfrieren als Wizard.
Also manchmal resisten sie das natürlich.
Du kannst Gegner einfrieren, du kannst Mops einfrieren.
Die Möglichkeit, wenn ich X drücke, kann ich den nächsten Spell instant casten und sowas.
Das ist schon echt geil.
Wizard ist eine super Klasse zum Einstieg finde ich auch.
Und wenn sie einem Spaß macht, kann man so weiterspielen. Also es gibt keinen Grund, warum man den Wizard nicht weiterspielen sollte.
Wizard ist eines der besten Klassen in dem Game.
Aber zum Einsteigen ist Wizard gut. Du brauchst keine Tränke, du bist jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig irgendwie abhängig von irgendwas.
Deine Spells machen Damage, du hältst trotz dem man Wizard ist genug aus.
Also Wizard anzufangen ist nicht verkehrt.
Und wenn man sich da ein bisschen auskennt mit dem Spiel, kann man immer noch sagen, ich würde gerne was anderes spielen.
Und dann hat man mit dem Wizard immer noch eine Klasse, die man im Zweifelsfall bei Karanda oder irgendwelchen Bossen abstellen kann.
Ich brauche mehr Basis, zu wenig Basis hier.
Hab ich schlecht gerollt mit dem Krieger? Nee, Krieger ist auch gut.
Es gibt eigentlich keine so richtigen K-Klassen.
Monster-Baschen kannst du mit allen Klassen ohne Probleme.
Manche sind halt einfacher, beziehungsweise ein bisschen schneller.
Also mit dem Wizard Grind ist er halt schneller als mit einem Ranger.
Selbst Musa ist mittlerweile gut. Musa wurde gebufft.
Letzten oder vorletzten Patch.
Also Musa war ja schon immer PvPvM, also gegen Monster immer ziemlich gut.
Jetzt ist er wohl auch in PvP ganz brauchbar.
Hast du schon mal LoL gespielt?
Also Mobas, muss ich sagen, ist nicht so mein Spielegenre.
Ich habe ein bisschen Hots gespielt, als er rausgekommen ist.
Also ja, hier Blizzard, MOBA.
Beziehungsweise eins ist Beta war noch sogar.
Also nur, als jemand gerade noch mal gesagt hat.
Also Wizard ist zum Einstieg wirklich gut.
Ich habe ja mit Bersi angefangen, das ging auch.
Weil ich halt jemand hatte, der es mit dem Game auskennt.
Aber Wizard macht mir viel mehr Spaß.
Und das Schöne an Wizard ist halt auch, ich muss nichts großartig machen.
Ich brauche hier drei, vier Spells.
Ich meine, ich habe mehr, ich könnte mehr machen, wenn ich will.
Aber muss ich nicht, ich kann jetzt hier ohne Probleme Kreiselgrinden und Chat lesen.
Das ist halt super entspannt.
Genau, in Hots konnte man mit dem Pferd zu 60s fahren.
Richtig.
Hey Max, bei einer 100k Leitung kommen gerade starke 2000 an.
Kann ich außer Router neu starten, sonst noch was machen?
Anbieterskabel Deutschland.
Ja, du kannst bei deinem Anbieter anrufen und fragen, was da los ist.
Allerdings, bei Kabel, das ist ja in der Regel so, dass sich da die Infrastruktur geteilt wird.
Von den Leuten, die da halt einergleichen hängen.
Und heute ist Feiertag.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es an anderen Feiertagen bei dir aussieht.
Vielleicht gibt es einfach an Feiertagen, wenn es viele benutzen nicht mehr her.
Ist es sonst auch so oder ist es nur heute so?
Und wie sieht es an anderen Feiertagen aus?
Wie ist es mit den Drops bei den World Rates aus?
Wie wird das Loot aufgeteilt?
Es gibt zwei, es gibt zwei Loot Tables, je nachdem, wie viel Damage du gemacht hast.
Umso mehr, so höher ist die Chance, was zu kriegen.
Also beim World Boss kriegst du ja, also wenn man jetzt bei Karanda kriegst du ja Auren oder halt direkt die Waffe.
Beides ist nicht schlecht.
Das heißt, man sollte auf jeden Fall gucken, dass man da jetzt nicht mit dem größten Kackheld von sich hingeht, da kein Damage macht.
Sondern schon mit irgendwas, was ein bisschen Damage fährt.
Erstens geht es schneller und man kann vielleicht noch auf einen zweiten Channel und auch nochmal den Boss abgreifen.
Das darf man auch nicht vergessen.
Man kann auf mehreren Channels den Boss machen, die spawnen alle zur gleichen Zeit.
Und wenn man Damage fährt, hat man eine bessere Chance, was zu kriegen.
Wie ist das mit Gruppencrime in BDO?
Bekommt man da die gleiche XP?
Da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Ich glaube, das war so, dass du dir halt die XP teilst, die die Mops haben.
Ich muss kurz meinen Headset entwehren nebenbei.
Du teilst dir die XP, die die Mops haben, aber du bekommst, glaube ich, einen minimalen Bonus für jeden, der in der Gruppe ist.
Ich glaube, irgendwie bei einem 20%, 30%, 40% und 50% oder irgendwie so.
Das reicht aber nicht dafür, dass du mehr XP kriegst als solo bei einfachen Mops.
Wenn du jetzt an andere Spots gehst, wo die Mops mehr XP geben und ein bisschen stärker sind, dann lohnt sich das da auch in Gruppe zu cripen.
Ich bin mal mit der Gruppen-XP-Verteilung nicht so wirklich sicher.
Ich glaube, das war irgendwie 20%, 30%, 40%, 50%.
Und es gibt halt Spots wie hier, wo halt nicht wirklich viel XP bei rumkommt.
Aber halt Kohle und Drops.
Weil es sich mit Drops hier gerade in Grenzen hält.
Kostet das Game im Monat? Nee.
Es kostet einmalig.
Und dann, je nachdem, was du an Microtransactions ausgeben willst.
Von denen keine sein müssen, manche sind aber ganz praktisch.
Also zum Beispiel Inventarplätze oder wie viel Gewicht du tragen kannst und Storageplätze.
Oder ein Value-Pack und Pets und sowas, das ist schon ganz praktisch.
Muss man sich aber nicht unbedingt direkt zu Beginn kaufen, wenn man sich das Game einfach mal angucken will.
Also kaufen muss man sich ja prinzipiell gar nicht.
Aber manche Sachen sind einfach praktisch.
Zeig mal dein Gear oder zeig mal dein Inventar.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Gear.
Dann hast du das aktuelle Gear.
Das Einzige, was sich geändert hat, ist, dass die Awakening-Waffe mittlerweile ein bisschen geupgraded ist und ist gelb.
Hat 2 AP mehr.
Komm mal, wer da ist.
Der Frazier ist am Start.
Nein, der Friesmeister.
Der Friesmeister.
Wie ist denn hier gute Basi-Rotation?
Kostet bei Steam gerade 5 Euro.
Dafür kann man sich das mal angucken.
Also es gibt eine Testversion in 7 Tagen.
Kann man sich auch so einfach mal angucken.
Und dann kann man sich immer noch entscheiden, was man sich für eine Version kaufen will.
Die Version mit Pferdeflöten und Value Packs ist preisleistungsmäßig gar nicht so schlecht.
Wir haben letztens im Stream mal ausgerechnet, was die Value Packs kosten.
Und was das Zeug kosten würde, wenn man sich das im Shop kauft.
Also nur die sinnvollen Sachen, die dabei sind.
Also die Inventarplätze und die Value Packs und sowas.
Und es kostet im Shop eine ganze Ecke mehr, als wenn man sich eben die bessere BDO Edition kauft.
Wo kann man das testen?
Weiß das jemand?
Wie kann man die Testversion spielen?
Es gibt auf jeden Fall eine 7-Tage-Testversion.
Ja, das weiß ich.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wo man die kriegt.
Wahrscheinlich auf der BDO-Seite, oder?
Oder muss man da irgendwie mit Freundesinvite rumhantieren?
Der Wizard killt eh alles.
Ich frage mich, wie das abgeht, Fabian, wenn ich dann die Awakening-Dande habe auf 3.
Dann ist wahrscheinlich alles One-Shot hier.
Basis sind alle weg.
So schnell gebashed.
Okay, also gibt es wohl auf der Seite.
Da gibt es bestimmt irgendwo...
Ich meine, die wären ja auch blöd, wenn sie keine Trial-Version anbieten würden.
Viele Leute haben halt natürlich ein bisschen...
Also schreuen auch fort, dass sie sagen, ich gebe jetzt Kohle für ein Game aus, obwohl
ich keine Ahnung habe, ob es mir gefällt.
Deswegen so eine Trial-Version.
Und 7 Tage ist bei BDO auch eigentlich genug.
In 7 Tagen kannst du, wenn du dich mit dem Game beschäftigst, wenn Schar quasi schon
fast ausgelevelt haben...
Aber wenn man es übertreibt, ja.
Manchmal, wenn man neu ist, muss man sich erstmal ein bisschen reinfinden.
Aber in 7 Tagen kann man sich das Game...
Da kann man viel sehen von dem Game.
Der Wobbler-OP.
Oh, Buff-Food.
Wo sind wir denn jetzt?
Bei EXP, oder?
Bei EXP?
Bei...
Nee, hier sind wir jetzt.
Und Food ist all.
Muss Food kaufen.
Okay, der Basi-Crime ist bald zu Ende.
Mach lieber Zen-Towers.
Ich habe heute Morgen aber schon Zen-Towers gemacht.
Ich hatte keinen Bock mehr auf Zen-Towers.
Der Sound von den Zen-Towers ging mir so auf den Keks.
Also, Fabian, ich habe schon...
Wir haben Katri-Daily abgegeben, Basi-Daily abgegeben, Zen-Tower-Daily abgegeben, beziehungsweise
erstmal die Zen-Tower-Quest überhaupt gemacht.
Gibt es sonst noch irgendwas Gutes, was ich lohnen würde zu machen?
Also außer, außer Story-Quests.
Auf die habe ich jetzt keinen Bock.
Auf den Keks.
Ja, der war schlecht.
Wir könnten, wir könnten den 9000-Spot zu zweit crimeen.
Falls du schon fit bist und dein Besuch das zulässt.
Gharas-Daily, Red-Battle-Feed-Daily.
Gharas-Daily machen wir noch.
Da habe ich jetzt Bock drauf.
Das war ein bisschen was anderes.
Wir machen jetzt Gharas-Daily.
GgEats.
Gharas-Daily.
Machen wir jetzt.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Kann man in dem Spiel als Clan große Gruppe was machen?
Also PvP-Offensichtliche ist so das offensichtlichste.
Gilden-PvP.
Oder sich mit anderen Gilden im Open-Wall-PvP um irgendwelche Spots prügeln.
Ach ja, weil ich vorhin noch ein paar PvP vergessen habe.
Ganz wichtig zu sagen.
Ich habe ja nur erklärt wie das ist, wenn man jetzt Leute PK't.
Wenn man in einer Gilde ist, ohne anderen Gilde den Krieg erklärt,
dann kann man sich gegenseitig so viel bashen wie man will ohne Abzüge.
Das ist eigentlich auch ganz wichtige Sache, das habe ich vorhin voll vergessen zu erzählen.
Also es muss wohl schon hier oben übelste Gildenkriege gegeben haben auf der Insel hier oben um diesen Spot.
Das ist so einer der besten XP und Money-Money-Spots.
Es ging dann so weit, dass sie da wohl irgendwelche Kriegselefanten auf die Insel gefahren haben mit dem Boot.
Und als Pets ausgepackt, weiß gar nicht wie man das Zeug verwendet, um sich da oben um den XP-Spot zu kloppen.
Ja und Cryantechnisch kann es natürlich eine Gruppe auch was machen.
Es gibt halt auch Spots wo die Mops nicht so kacke sind wie hier.
So wir gehen jetzt mal zum Gaul raus.
Da haben wir mal Gharhas Daily Cryant.
Das ist auch noch gut, bisschen Abwechslung schadet nichts.
Was macht der Basi da eigentlich? Da hatte ich jetzt 3x im Kreis gedreht und nicht einmal gehitted.
Und wenn uns dann ganz langweilig ist, dann machen wir noch 1000 Daily Quests.
Ja das BDO Wegfindung FTW, das ist die beste Wegfindung aller Zeiten.
Da kann mein Navi also wirklich einpacken.
1000 Lohn ist vom Geld her schon ein Problem.
Das machen wir, wir machen nachher noch 1000 Daily Quests.
Und vielleicht können wir ja ein paar Noobs bashen.
Noch größere Noobs.
Sag mal Moment, was mache ich da eigentlich?
Da muss ich hin.
Wo habe ich denn mal ein Pferd abgestellt?
Ich habe mal ein Pferd hier unten bei dem Typ abgestellt oder?
Ja irgendwo da, das passt schon. Die Wegfindung ist einfach nur Crap.
Da muss man einfach einmal hier drum herum laufen und gut ist.
Jetzt haben wir erst mal Garas Daily, das ist eine gute Idee.
Hier haben wir doch unser Pferd irgendwo abgestellt.
Die Anzeige auf der Map ist auch schon Fail.
Okay, haben wir noch genug. Jetzt können wir hier oben in Wout packen, das passt ja.
Sehen wir noch ein bisschen was von der Spielwelt.
Da können wir auch gleich unser Pferdeequipment reparieren.
Toxic as fuck. Wer ist toxic as fuck?
Das ist doch kein Overwatch ranked.
Ich habe eigentlich gar keinen Bock die Placements heute zu spielen, weil ich weiß, ich reg mich schon wieder auf.
Oder ich weiß, ich reg mich dann wieder auf, garantiert.
Es ist nicht möglich Overwatch ranked zu spielen, ohne sich aufzuregen.
Das Beste ist, wir kommen jetzt an Garas an, machen dann quasi Garas Daily.
Wahrscheinlich 500 Banitenbashen oder sowas.
Und es ist direkt Nacht, kriegen wir nochmal mehr Exp.
Haben wir unsere 2% voll.
Also easy 61 dann.
Ich meine, es geht echt.
Wir haben jetzt nicht wirklich effektiv irgendwie gegrindet oder sowas, schon was 2%.
Mir fehlen noch 9 Skillpunkte.
Alles was ich brauche, Awakening technisch.
Oh, gib mal ein bisschen Gas Wubbler.
Das verkaufen wir noch gleich.
Ich glaube, man kann Pferde keinen Namen geben in PTO.
Oder kann man Pferde, doch klar kann man Pferde Namen geben.
Wubbler, schneller.
Der Weg da oben nach Shakatu zieht sich immer.
Wir sind im Endeffekt jetzt ja einfach nur von, dumm Weg geritten eigentlich.
Von da nach da geritten.
Das zieht sich aber immer, Wahnsinn.
Pferd, please.
Ich habe noch kein neues Pferd.
Brauchen wir noch, aber nicht sinnlos Geld rausschmeißen.
Erst mal meine Dande auf 3 machen und dann kann man mal gucken.
Gibt es hier was zum Sell?
Brauche Händler.
Storage, das da verkaufen, Sell, jawoll.
Perfekt.
So, Kahas Daily annehmen und dann ist Nacht.
Das ist perfektes Timing.
Ich liebe es aber, wenn man lange braucht, um irgendwo hinzukommen in MMOs.
Deswegen mochte ich das Teleportieren in Final Fantasy 14 nicht.
Ich finde auch, man muss es mit dem Schnellreisesystem nicht übertreiben.
Es gibt zwei Sachen, wo ich finde, dass es die komplette Spielwelt von MMOs zerstören kann.
Das erste ist ein scheiß Schnellreisesystem, was kacke umgesetzt ist.
Und das nächste ist Flying Mounds.
Ich finde, Flying Mounds ist eines der bescheuersten Ideen, die sie jemals in MMOs hatten.
Weil die meisten Maps sind ja für Bodenzeug optimiert und gebaut.
Und weil man da in dem Gebiet fliegen darf, setzt das alle natürlichen Grenzen auf den Maps außer Kraft.
Plus noch ein Buff, jawoll, jetzt geht es ab.
Und führt dazu, dass die Spielwelt auch weniger belebt ist.
Ich finde, Flying Mounds finde ich total beknackt.
So aus Gameplay und spielerischer Sicht.
Ich meine, es ist cool, Flying Mounds zu haben.
Also zu Map-Design technisch und für die ganze Spielwelt finde ich das beknackt, Flying Mounds.
Also Flying Mounds selbst macht Spaß, keine Frage.
Aber ich finde es für die Spielwelt nicht gut.
Aber das nächste ist natürlich ein blödes Schnellreißensystem.
Und beides in Kombination, ich habe die Daily nicht angenommen.
Beides in Kombination führt dazu, dass die Spielwelt plus Instanz und alles Mögliche,
dass die Spielwelt leerer wirkt, als sie eigentlich ist.
Ein MMO, in dem die Spielwelt leer wirkt, wirkt irgendwie tot, obwohl es nicht tot ist.
Das nächste ist ein MMO, in dem die Spielwelt leerer wirkt, als sie eigentlich ist.
Ja, leg dich nicht mit dem Wuppler an.
Ich habe übrigens ganze zwei Spells gedrückt, um den Bersi zu killen.
Aber so laufen Fights in BDO ab, wenn das Gear von dem einen einfach viel besser ist, als das Gear von dem anderen.
Moment, die machen mir hier meine Mobs streitig.
Da muss ich oben Gas Rotation machen.
Manchmal oben Gas Rotation, das ist eh besser auf dem Berg.
Casual Bersi, ja das stimmt.
Dabei hätte mich jeder halbwegs gute Bersi instant gekrappt und geregt.
Ich stand ja im Gesicht von dem.
Wie lange brauchst du für Level 61, geschätzt?
Na ja, guck mal, du siehst ja, wie langsam die XP geht.
Die Mobs geben hier sogar ganz gut XP.
Und es ist XP-Buff an.
Es ist Nacht.
Ich habe XP, T und 50%.
Also ich kriege ja quasi schon jetzt mal 200, ein bisschen mehr als 200% mehr XP.
Und es geht immer noch langsam.
Keine Ahnung, wie lang dauert es denn? 500 Stunden oder so?
Kann ich nicht richtig schätzen.
500 Stunden, oder?
50 Stunden, echt?
Nee, oder? So kurz nur.
Das ist ja nichts, also 50 Stunden wäre ja nichts.
Ja, wahrscheinlich geht es echt viel schneller, als man sich das so denkt.
Keine Ahnung, wie lange es dauert.
Du machst in einer Stunde mit allen Buffs 2%.
Ja, doch gut, dann geht es wirklich schnell.
Dann geht es echt schnell.
Easy, easy 61.
Auf geht's.
Also ich finde, 50 Stunden sind schnell.
Wenn man sich überlegt, das ist ja quasi schon absolut High-End-Level.
61.
Dafür sind 50 schon schnell.
Und man braucht es ja noch nicht mal unbedingt.
Ich glaube, der höchste in Korea ist 63.
Und 63 ist quasi auch nicht zu erreichen, so richtig.
Also da musst du wahrscheinlich 3 Jahre oder so, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, wann das Game in Korea rauskommt.
Sonst musst du da 2 Jahre durchgrinden.
Und spätestens dort alles drüber ist eigentlich in normaler Zeit nicht zu packen.
Da müsstest du wahrscheinlich das Game 15 Jahre spielen
und jeden Tag 10 plus Stunden cripen oder so für 64.
Ist auch ein bisschen wenig Mops, ne?
Ich stelle es bestimmt schon einer rum.
Das ist so ein Unterschied.
Ich habe ja hier gelevelt auf 58, glaube ich.
Das ist ein riesen Unterschied jetzt.
Vom Dir von damals zu jetzt.
Mega Unterschied.
Wo ist denn hier so ein wenig Mops?
Mega Unterschied ist das.
Scheiße, warum ist das hier so voll?
Was soll das?
Piss dich, Alde.
Ey, gibt es doch nicht.
Ich dachte mir, hier oben ist bestimmt weniger los.
Hier ist ja noch, hier ist ja noch mehr.
Hier ist ja gar nichts mehr an Mops da.
Alter.
Alter, Alter.
Geh ich wieder runter.
Ah, ich jumpe da jetzt runter irgendwo.
Eigentlich ist da oben ein bester Spot.
Hat man in der Regel seine Ruhe.
Wir machen jetzt Main Rotation.
Wir killen die einfach.
Wir killen den Bersi nochmal.
Ich weiß noch, wie ich mir einen abgebrochen habe hier auf 58 gegen die Mops.
Und jetzt einer eh alles tot.
Das war echt ein riesen Unterschied.
Irgendein Koreaner 63 habe ich auch gelesen.
Gibt es eigentlich in NA schon jemand, der 63 ist?
Also NA ohne EU, gibt es da schon jemand, der 63 ist?
Wisst ihr das?
Ja, und Zielkrampf wünscht ihr auch.
Easy Clap 2k18.
Auf das alles Easy Clap sein wird.
Das ist so geil mittlerweile.
Wie ich mir hier einen abgebrochen habe mit 58 ist der Wahnsinn.
Jetzt gehst du einfach hin, drückst einen Spell, BAM, Mops tot, NEXT.
BAM, NEXT.
Das ist total Easy Mode.
Zack, NEXT.
Wie die einfach umkippen.
Geiler Wizard.
Was vor zwei Wochen ist das jemand in den NA 62 geworden?
Da sieht man mal, was das für ein riesen, das ist echt krass.
Wieder die EXP Kurve hoch geht.
Mittlerweile bis 60 ziemlich easy.
Sogar bis 61, wenn man sich das mal oben anguckt, noch relativ easy.
Und danach steigt es aber krass an.
Hier sind Leute, zu wenig Mops.
Aber wir machen den Irrotation jetzt mal komplett kaputt.
Die werden sich bestimmt freuen.
Das hält auch keine Natur durch James Bong.
Das geht doch nicht.
Wobei das in Koreaner vielleicht doch geht.
Aber das geht doch nicht.
Du kannst doch nicht 8 Stunden arbeiten, 14 Stunden crying, 2 Stunden schlafen.
Das geht doch nicht.
Und selbst dann musst du das ja ein paar Monate lang machen.
Da verreckste doch.
Da kratzt du doch ab, da stirbst du doch bei.
Na gut, ich meine, es sind nicht umsonst.
Da gibt es ja immer mal wieder News, dass aus den Internet Cafés in Korea
irgendwelche Leute tot rausgezogen werden, weil sie da quasi halb dehydriert
30 Stunden am Stück Overwatch gespielt haben.
Ah, der Berser ist wieder da.
Armer Berser.
Shrek Berser.
Tja, so nicht.
Easy Crap Combo.
Der Berser hat einfach Kack hier, würde ich sagen.
Da ist ja noch mehr da.
Hier so viele Leute.
Oh, da ist ein DK.
Auf den habe ich jetzt keinen Bock.
Ah, hier oben sind aber noch Webster.
Der Berser, der Berser ist der übelste Casual.
Das merkste klar.
Ich meine, dass ich Crap lässt von mir als Berser, als einer der besten
Movement-Klassen eigentlich im Game, ja, dann, na.
Deswegen habe ich auch in dem Game gar nicht so großartige PvP-Ambitionen,
weil es gibt immer genug Noobs, die man bashen kann.
Das ist ja ein Zielkram.
Es sind, jetzt sage ich doch, es sind schon Koreaner in PC-Banks,
in ihren Internet-Cafés.
Wow.
Wizard, das übertreibt es mal nicht.
Sind schon an Erschöpfung, Dehydrierung und alle möglichen gestorben,
weil sie zu lange gespielt haben.
Ach guck mal, wer da ist, der Berser.
Der wird jetzt reingefickt.
Ich glaube, der Berser mag mich nicht mehr.
Wie viel Gas brauchen wir noch?
200 ungefähr.
Okay, der hier ist zu voll.
Das sackt einfach nur.
Der Berser, der hat das für alle jetzt aus sich.
Der Berser, der ist echt geil.
Eigentlich hätte man den DK danach auch noch pickern müssen.
Der hat ja nur noch 10% Leben.
Oder?
Also, habt ihr jetzt so im Hinterkopf, der hat nicht mehr viel Leben gehabt.
Machen wir hier Mobs, ist egal.
Wir machen unsere Daily fertig.
Expen noch ein bisschen.
Ich meine, die Nacht können wir ausnutzen.
Nacht und Golden Bell.
Und hier ist auch, das ist eigentlich ein ganz guter XP-Spot.
Plus, dass es auch noch ganz gut Geld gibt.
Rotieren wir hier immer noch ein bisschen rum.
Ein hotter Berser?
Ich glaube, das ist schwierig.
Ein hotter Riese.
Wie kommt es, dass du ihn angreifen kannst?
Das liegt daran, was er mich vorher angegriffen hat.
Also, wenn du jemand angreifst und dann gebasht wirst, bist du für, ich weiß nicht, 2 Minuten oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange das ist.
Kannst du angegriffen werden noch.
Also, wenn du dich jetzt PvP fleckst und mich angreifst, dann kannst du dich auch direkt wieder entflecken.
Aber das dauert kurz.
Ich meine, weil sonst kannst du dich ja PvP flecken.
Jemand anhippen.
Hoffen, dass er von den Monstern gekillt wird.
Dich entflecken quasi.
Er könnte dich nicht angreifen, außer sich selbst zu flecken.
Das wäre ja Griefing ohne Ende, was du dann treiben könntest.
Wahrscheinlich gibt es jetzt gleich Ready Threat, Nerf Wizard.
Spielt jemand von euch Overwatch und hat seine Placements für die aktuelle Season schon gemacht?
Du machst sie gerade, okay.
Und wie läuft es?
Werden sie alle geschreckt?
Ach, hier unten grindet sich doch eigentlich auch ganz gut.
Das müsste doch auch im Kreis hier gehen.
Wieso?
Gucken wir mal.
Das ist so geil, Gas zu bashen jetzt mit ein bisschen besserer Ausrüstung.
Das war so mühselig auf 58.
Das macht gleich viel mehr Bock.
Alle Placements, was? Alleine sind Placements als Support-Mainscheid.
Ja, das stimmt.
Vor allem, wenn man gezwungen ist, Mercy zu spielen.
Wenn man Ana spielen kann, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber Ana ist halt nicht Meta gerade.
Sie ist Anti-Meta.
Bei Ana der beste Support ist Leballuzio.
Hier wird ja alles weg.
Dann kreisen wir hier weiter jetzt.
Im Prinzip, wo sind wir lang gegangen?
Nee, unten lang.
Wir machen jetzt noch bis die Nacht vorbei ist.
Snacken wir uns noch den XP-Bonus.
Guck mal, 2% schon.
Ist das wieder der Berser? Nein.
Hier ist so voll.
Symmetra oder Kreiselcrime?
Jeden Tag Kreiselcrime belebt die Seele.
So sieht es aus.
Endschweiler, das erkennt.
Kreiselcrime ist das Beste.
Vor allem, deswegen ist ja auch so geil, das zu streamen, das Game.
Du kannst Kreiselcrime machen.
Das erfordert jetzt nicht sonderlich viele Gehirnzellen, die man darauf verwenden muss.
Und du kannst halt...
Es ist halt nicht langweilig, wenn du Streams und Chat dabei hast.
Ansonsten, wenn man das alleine macht, ist es schon teilweise ermüdigend.
Also mit Chat dabei ist es top.
Mit Kreiselcrime ist es gemacht.
Du läufst halt im Kreis und killst Mobs.
Jetzt halt grind für Mobskill und halt im Kreis.
Daraus wird halt Kreiselcrime.
Moin Aschen denn.
Ja, ich bin auch wieder da.
Aber ich hab gepennt.
Also ich streame nicht seit gestern oder so.
Wir haben gestreamt gestern bis 1.30 Uhr ungefähr.
Und seit heute Morgen um ungefähr 10.
Die Mob-Sounds.
Ich sag euch Leute, es gibt irgendwie so eine geheime Sound-Datenband für MMOs,
die sich von allen Entwicklern auf dieser Welt für MMOs geteilt wird.
Weil Mob-Sounds in MMOs hören sich so ähnlich an in allen MMOs.
Bestes Sound von allen Mob-Sounds hatten immer noch die Trollen in Dark,
wenn sie gehitted wurden.
Hat jemand von euch Dark gespielt?
Hat jemand von euch Dark gespielt, der erinnert sich noch an die Troll-Sounds?
Und für alle die, also für alle die nicht wissen wie sich das anhört,
ich kann mal probieren das irgendwie nachzumachen.
Also Troll-Sounds in Dark haben sich ungefähr so angehört.
Weil wenn Troll gehitted wurde, hat er dann irgendwie sowas gemacht wie
So hat sich das angehört.
Troll-Sounds in Dark.
Das denken alle, der Max dreht ab, komplett durch.
Aber so waren Mob-Sounds Troll-Sounds in Dark.
Wahrscheinlich wurde auch der Sound genauso aufgenommen.
Da haben sie irgendeinen Typ vor das Mikrofon gesetzt und haben es dann
auch ein bisschen angepasst im Audio-Editor und fertig war der Troll-Sound.
Falls sich noch jemand an die Troll-Sounds aus Dark erinnert.
Ich blicke gerade nicht so genau durch, wo ich bin.
Bin ich denn?
Ah, hier geht es rauf.
Wir können ja mal oben gucken, ob oben wieder frei ist jetzt.
Dark soll eine Free-To-Play-Option bekommen.
Habe ich gelesen.
Ich habe immer durchgelesen, was die darunter verstehen.
Das ist ziemlich beknackt.
Also du kannst quasi Free-To-Play machen bis 3L9 oder so.
Und auch nicht jede Klasse.
So ganz merkwürdig.
Keine Ahnung, wer da spielen sollte.
Ich glaube, wo sie richtig punkten könnten ist, wenn sie einen neuen Dark-Server starten.
Mit ein paar Sachen gefixt, die halt vielen Leuten auf den Sack gegangen sind.
Und das Free-To-Play, einen neuen Server-Cluster Free-To-Play starten.
Ich glaube, das würde wirklich dazu führen, dass viele alte Veteranen wieder mal sich
das angucken und auch neue Leute.
Und dann, Fabian, dann fangen wir auch wieder an, oder?
Dann bashen wir die Noobs, wenn es einen neuen Free-To-Play-Server geben sollte.
Dann spielen wir ein bisschen und dann, bis uns das Camp-Camp auch mal macht.
Arschgeier.
Das wünsche ich besser habe.
Das wünschen wir dir auch alle.
Easy Clap 2K18.
Money!
Fuck.
Frohes Neues an alle.
Kiyoko, danke.
Fünf Euro.
Quasi Sub.
Du hast quasi gesubbt, wenn man so will.
Ohne Sub-Button.
Ich brauche noch irgendeinen doofen Spruch, wenn Leute subben.
Also, wenn ich doch mal irgendwie Partner werde.
Es haben ja alle irgendwie einen komischen Spruch, wenn die Leute subben, ja.
XQC erzählt irgendwas von Welcome to the Jungle.
Prime Sub.
Oder sowas in der Richtung.
Wen haben wir da sonst noch so?
Cyrus erzählt irgendwas von Family.
Ich brauche auch noch irgendeinen blöden Spruch, wenn einer subbt.
Da muss ich mal in mich gehen.
Profi-Kreisel-Kreiner-Club.
Profi-Kreisel-Stellz-Club.
Keine Ahnung.
Muss ich mir irgendwas Blödes ausdenken.
Keks-Armee.
Oh nee, das ist dumm.
Das ist viel zu nahe liegend, Keks-Armee.
Lindendark-Troll-Sound.
Ich muss dann jedes Mal mit einer Sub machen.
Das könnte ein bisschen anstrengend für die Stimmbänder werden, falls viele subben.
Keks-Fabrik.
Keks-Fabrik ist gut.
Das finde ich schon ein bisschen besser.
Genau, Nopo ist jetzt offiziell ein Keks.
Ich weiß nicht, ich muss mir da irgendwas ausdenken.
Aber noch, wie gesagt, ich habe ja immer noch nicht Twitch kontaktiert.
Habe ich jetzt auch erst wieder, wenn hier, ganz normal, wenn hier wieder Alltag eingekehrt
ist.
Keks-Fabrik.
Ja, Evoli, da hast du recht.
Eigentlich muss das irgendwas komplett auf abgedrehtem Gaming-Danglish sein.
Der Fabian könnte bei sich sagen, wenn einer subscribt, dass irgendwas mit das Mattert nicht.
Ich benutze den Name Mattert jetzt nicht mehr.
Es muss aber irgendwie abgedrehtes Gaming-Danglish sein.
Wo hat er jetzt seinen Zauberkart hingemacht, der geile Wizard?
Da muss ich mir echt irgendwas ausdenken.
Aber erst mal muss ich Twitch anschreiben und fragen, wie es aussieht, was man da machen
muss und wie das läuft und so.
Hab da mich doch null mit beschäftigen.
Ah, Elite-Mod.
Mal gucken, wie gut ich die jetzt down kriege im Vergleich zu früher.
Easy-Clap, das kann ja gar nichts mehr.
Hohohoho.
Ja, ich hab früher abgebrochen bei den Moppen.
Oh, ich hab vorbei geklickt.
Oh, easy.
Kann ja gar nichts mehr.
Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung, welches Xp-Food jetzt dran ist?
Welches Buff-Food jetzt dran ist?
Ich bin da so verplant, ich kann mir das ums Verrecken nicht merken.
Duo-Crash-Method.
Ja, das merkt man richtig.
Was ist jetzt dran?
Xp?
Xp-Buff-Food ist dran, ne?
Xp.
Milk-Tea, ja.
Wie ich keinen Bock hab, morgen arbeiten zu gehen, das ist echt schlimm.
Jetzt verarschen wir sie.
Wenn sie debatet, wir grinden einfach in die entgegengesetzte Richtung.
Damit rechnen sie nicht.
Gegen-Grind-Rotation.
Gegen den Uhrzeigers in Kreiselgrind.
Ne, Affiliate ist doof.
Affiliate kriegste quasi nur ein, kriegste viel weniger Emotes und alles.
Guck mal, da ist der Bersi.
Ist das der Berser?
Ne, ich glaub das ist ein anderer Berser.
Okay, machen wir die Rotation oben drüber wieder.
Einmal können wir die Rotation hier oben noch machen, dann ist sieben Uhr.
Und wir geben einfach die Quest ab, wenn gut ist.
Pets müssen auch mal gefüttert werden.
Neun, zwei, sechs, zwei.
Oh, die Leute sind weg.
Können wir hier oben weiter machen.
Wie findest du die Mystique-Klasse?
Nicht ausprobiert und eigentlich kein Interesse dran, genauso wie Striker.
Jo, mich nicht.
Da dasht da sich ein ab.
Machen wir doch wieder unsere Grind-Rotation unten.
Ich sag bloß noch ne Ingame-Stunde, Ingame eineinhalb Stunden.
Machen wir hier unsere Rotation.
Also Mystique und Striker interessieren mich gar nicht.
Da muss ich auch sagen, ich spiel das Game ziemlich, also immer mit größeren Unterbrechungen.
Ich hab mich jetzt auf Wizard festgelegt, ich bleib auch definitiv erstmal auf Wizard.
Ich hab keinen Bock irgendwie neue Waffen wieder kaufen zu müssen, entschalten zu müssen oder so.
Außerdem macht mir Wizard übelst Bock.
Und Wizard ist allround-mäßig ne richtig gute Klasse.
Kann man eigentlich nix verkehrt machen.
Deswegen bleib ich jetzt erstmal, auch alles kaputt, bleib ich auf jeden Fall erstmal Wizard.
Vielleicht sollten wir einfach doch jetzt Quest abgeben, wenn gut ist.
Eindeutig zu viele Leute da.
Wobei hier ist Respawn.
Dann machen wir doch noch, gehen wir einmal noch im Kreis und dann geben wir ab.
Dann muss man mal gucken, was wir machen.
Ich hab's jetzt seit drei Stunden nicht geschafft.
Ich hab jetzt innerhalb von drei Stunden geschafft von meinem Frühstück quasi ein Brötchen Fass zu essen und das andere liegt noch da.
Nicht so langsam aber sicher ziemlich Hunger.
Striker ist zur Zeit ziemlich als OP.
Und wahrscheinlich müsste ich dann auch nach Awakening, keine Ahnung.
Muss man mal gucken.
Ausrufezeichen Gear, Anaxuna, Exclamation Mark Gear.
Hier alle Schrecken.
Und dann muss ich mal gucken, wie ich das mit Mittagessen mache.
Ich bin dann, ich bin gleich mal kurz fünf Minuten ab.
Hier unten am Quest NPC.
Wenn wir gleich am Quest NPC sind, bin ich mal kurz fünf Minuten ab, guck mal wegen Mittagessen.
Dann bin ich aber wieder da. Also ich werde noch ein bisschen Streamsauen heute.
Zumal das liegt einfach daran, wie gesagt, ich muss ja morgen wieder arbeiten, ich hab keinen Bock.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht streamen würde, würde ich mir den ganzen Tag Gedanken drüber machen.
Oh Alter, hast du keinen Bock morgen auf die Arbeit zu gehen, so eine Kacke.
Deswegen streamen soll ich jetzt einfach, da mach ich mir um sowas keine Gedanken.
Das nervt mich echt.
Dandewen, ähm, 14 Tage.
Also wenn die Rewards ungefähr so sind wie diesen Monat, wovon auszugehen ist.
Ich meine, das war jetzt die letzten Monate immer ziemlich ähnlich.
Also sprich, wenn die Rewards, wenn es hier wieder Seals gibt am 14.
Oder in 14 Tagen dann, wenn die Rewards starten, dann ist Dandewen am Start.
Was arbeitest du denn, das dir nicht gefällt? Mir gefällt es ja.
Mir gefällt es ja, aber ich hatte jetzt einen Monat Urlaub, musst du dir mal vorstellen.
Ich hatte einen Monat Urlaub und ich hab nie Bock nach dem Urlaub wieder auf die Arbeit zu gehen.
Das ist immer ganz ätzend, also richtig ätzend.
Sobald ich dann wieder da bin, ist alles gut, finde ich, finde ich okay.
Das ist immer nur, wenn ich so lange Urlaub gehabt habe, dann will ich nicht.
Aber ich glaube, das geht jedem so.
Oder? Ich meine, das ist doch bei vielen wahrscheinlich jetzt gerade ähnlich.
Ihr hattet jetzt auch Urlaub oder zumindest ein paar Tage frei.
Ihr habt doch bestimmt auch keinen Bock.
Ich muss mal auf den Berser gucken. Das ist der komische Bersi, der mich vorher ownen wollte.
Nicht, dass er sich jetzt denkt, ich stehe AFK am Pferd und er kann mich ownen.
Pass mal auf, den gibaten wir jetzt, den gibaten wir jetzt.
Er denkt bestimmt, ich bin AFK, der kommt gleich wieder, der kommt gleich wieder.
Guck, der bleibt extra in Range, dass er mich sieht.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich dachte, den können wir jetzt baiten, dass er denkt, ich bin AFK und greift mich nochmal an.
Können wir ihn nochmal bashen.
Gut, dann reite ich mal zurück nach Shakatu und guck mal kurz für ihn Mittagessen.
Aber ich bin gleich wieder da.
Wie gesagt, ich lasse ja auch alles an und so, ich bin einfach nur mal kurz hier nicht am Rechner.
Wenn ich in der Stadt angekommen bin.
Du hast noch eine Woche Urlaub, ja das sei froh.
Ich meine, ich hatte jetzt echt lange Urlaub.
Komplett im Dezember, oder?
Du hast eigentlich nie Bock.
Ja gut, das gibt es natürlich auch.
Das ist auch eine Variante.
Ich habe an sich eigentlich Bock, worauf ich keinen Bock habe, ist 5.50 Uhr wieder aufzustehen.
Ich meine, ich müsste nicht 5.50 Uhr aufstehen.
Ich könnte auch später aufstehen, die Sache ist die.
Ich stehe ja freiwillig 5.50 Uhr auf, dass ich kurz vor 7.00 Uhr auf der Arbeit bin und 15.00 Uhr schon wieder abhauen kann.
Das ist ja gerade zum Zweck der Sache.
Ich habe auch den restlichen Tag Zeit, was anderes zu machen.
Unter anderem halt YouTube oder irgendwas streamen oder so.
Was halt nicht gilt, wenn ich erst irgendwie um 10.00 Uhr oder so aufstehe, schrägstrich anfange.
Und dann bis 17.00 Uhr auf der Arbeit rumspringe.
Okay Leute, ich bin mal ganz kurz nach Essen, gleich wieder da.
Ich bin mal ganz kurz nach Essen, gleich wieder da.
So, wieder am Start, haben wir noch ein paar Nudelreste, werde ich mal gleich machen.
So, nice, gut, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Jetzt müssen wir, wir müssen eigentlich mal, oder ich müsste mal mein ganzes Zeug, was
ich so über die Spielwelt verteilt hab, also das ist ja nicht viel, das ist ja nur hier,
hier und in Altinova müsste ich mal nach Velia bringen.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass wenn Pferdesachen einmal komplett kaputt sind, dass man die
nie wieder repariert bekommt?
Doch, nee, geht doch, man kann bloß nicht draufklicken.
Weil BDO, so, selber den ganzen Shit mal, Gaha Steals geben immer ganz gut Kohle, resten
Scrolls, also wir bringen den ganzen Mist jetzt mal nach Velia, dann, in der Zeit können wir
mal überlegen, was wir machen.
So genau weiß ich, dass er mich schon hat, Gaha Steals, 1.000 Daily, 1.000 Daily machen
wir noch, 1.000 Daily machen wir noch, easy, 1.000 Daily ist gut, können wir mal bei 1.000
ein paar Typen bashen, die Spot Take beschreiben.
Dieses VR Chat ist ja mal übelst gehyped, ja, ist auch teilweise ganz lustig anzugucken,
den ganzen Tag gucken müsste ich das jetzt nicht, dann schaut es irgendwann ein bisschen
langweilig, aber schön ist es teilweise ganz witzig zu gucken, je nachdem bei wem.
Und vielleicht sollte ich nochmal, gerade noch mal einen Baul gucken, ob ich hier irgendwas
wichtiges noch liegen habe, ne, nur Crap, das fürs Pferd, easy, zieh mal dem Pferd mal
etwas an, dann sieht es nicht mehr so laggisch aus, jetzt hat so ein Ding auf dem Kopf, sieht
auch nicht besser aus oder, ne das sieht dumm aus, einfach nur auf dem Kopf so ein Teil,
ich hab, ich glaub in Velia hab ich noch Pferdeparts, kann man Pferd mal ein bisschen upgraden.
So, aber jetzt gehen wir erstmal Richtung Thousand Dailies machen, Spot Taken, komm
die ganzen, kommen sie alle wieder an gleich, buddy Spot is Taken, Spot Taken, please leave,
Spot Taken, äh Reiten, welche Streamer guckst du, boah ich hab total viele gefollowed, also
ich hab so ziemlich alle Overwatch Pros, die streamen, relativ viele Speedrunner, natürlich
die ganzen eSport Channels, Bob Ross nicht zu vergessen, ein paar Rainbow Six Channels,
Quake Live, Quake Champions und ein paar Let's Play Channels, also sowas wie Dance Gaming
und sowas, wobei ich muss ganz ehrlich, persönlicher Geschmack ja, ich find Dance Gaming ist der
beste Let's Player auf Twitch, ich kann mir das, ich guck mir den gerne an, vor allem
wenn er Kickstarter und Steamspiele, Angebote sich angucken, sowas, das ist immer übelst
und lustig, Dance Gaming ist für mich der beste Let's Player, also auf Twitch, auf YouTube
guck ich gar keine Let's Plays mehr mittlerweile, mein Lieblings Let's Player auf YouTube der
macht ja schon seit Jahren keine Videos mehr, Lyrik, nee guck ich net, die meisten großen
guck ich nicht, außer Dance Game, KappaPride, das war auch, habt ihr es gehört, das war
auch wieder so ein typischer Mob Sound aus der MMO Mob Sound Datenbank, den es auch in
dem MMO gibt, so Harpien Sounds und sowas, erstmal gucken, da ist mal ne Quest mit der
Einblende, ähm, ich bin mal kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz
auf dem Klo.
Ok, ich bin mal kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich
reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz
auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch
kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja
eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich
reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz
auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch
kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite
jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem Klo, ich reite jetzt ja eh noch kurz, kurz auf dem
ist es so 50 prozent macht der chat aus und 50 prozent quasi das stream
nimmst du nimmst du von twitch den stream weg wäre das für alle leute
offensichtlich dass twitch dann useless ist aber nimmst du den chat weg fehlt
finde ich genauso viel es ist einfach twitch und twitch ohne twitch chat das
geht nicht versteht ihr wie ich das meine das funktioniert nicht du musst
bar food kauft wunderbar sebaro dass du mir das sagst ich schreibe mir das hier
gerade mal nebenbei auf text datei weil wir machen jetzt erst mal 1.000
das erst mal 1.000 daily quest
danach habe ich eh keine ahnung was man machen soll
also ich finde es geht also wie gesagt ich gucke ja viel krabi
der channel ist folow krabi ehemaliger warcraft 3 pro der hat auch sagen wir so
je nachdem wann zwischen 2000 und 5000 unsere zuschauer das geht der chat ist
in ordnung ich meine klar der chat geht relativ schnell ist normal bei so viel
zuschauen aber man kann auch alles lesen es ist es geht es ist wirklich
nicht es ist angenehm noch wohingegen bei den bei den ganz bei den anderen
channels wo es halt auch darum geht einfach sinnloses zeugs zu spam da
blick sind immer durch was ich ganz schlimm finde sind
mittlerweile bei den großen speedrun events die gibt es ja gibt es ja jahre
jetzt schon ja und viele vieles twitty twitch copy gepaste kommt halt auch eben
auch von diesen speedrun channels und diesen speedrun events zum beispiel
dieses ganze grill und sowas zeugs anstatt girl das hat seine ursprünge
ziemlich sicher dort irgendwo und mittlerweile müssen sie halt gucken dass
die da so korrekt sind und sich da keiner auf den schlips getreten fühlt
und so dass spezielle emotes gesperrt sind ich glaube tryhard da kannst du
darfst du als emote nicht mehr verwenden und und du darfst auch nicht mal grill
schreiben und sowas irgendwie sich schon ganz hart über moderiert es macht kaum
noch spaß dann eigentlich den chat zu verwenden wenn wenn quasi dein
sinnlos gelaber direkt gleich geploggt wird und ich mein sinnlos gelaber macht
halt twitch chat aus
und vor allem ich finde man muss ja da auch irgendwie kein irgendwie
beschützen oder so ein wozu ja warum warum warum muss man warum muss man
grill blocken als als als wort ich darf nicht vergessen es gibt viele
medels bei diesen events die die haben das sogar im nicknames mittlerweile
weil es ist auch lustig finden und wenn es einen nicht lustig findet dann kann
er entweder sagt das oder ich meine er hält halt mal aus dass man ein bisschen
ich meine ich muss was ich mir auf youtube für eine scheiße in den
kommentaren immer durchlesen muss ja also ich habe es ja gestern gesagt seit
gs seit letztem video haben wir da leute geschrieb geschrieben hier angeblich ich
werde mal wieder nazi vor kannst du dir friseur erinnerst oder fabian erinnerst
ich noch an max flame account 123 der mir erzählt hat ich bin jude und wollte
mich beleidigen und so was ich mir für eine scheiße anhören muss auf youtube
ja da muss man auch durch und ich mein so ein bisschen dickes fell in dieser
richtung so ein bisschen nicht ganz so dünne dünne haut sollte man doch haben
dass man es auch wenn man jetzt beispielsweise ein mädchen ist und die
leute schreiben grill im chat und man findet es jetzt nicht so toll dass man
dann nicht klein dass er nicht gleich die welt untergeht
ist meine ansicht dazu ja ich meine leute die schwul sind mussten auch damit
auskommen in einer kappa breit im chat schreibt oder so ich meine muss man
halt dann das ist was ist dabei
oder kommen leute die ein bisschen dicker sind die da wieder schreiben das
spam die leute auch thick und sonst was rum im chat was was hast du da oder oder
ich will nicht wissen wie oft bei wenn irgendwie einer mit orissa einen guten
rechtklick setzt einer sack schreibt und sowas es ist halt ein bisschen blödes
gelaber muss kann man doch aushalten solange es halt in maßen bleibt ja und ich
meine ganz ehrlich grill ist jetzt nicht jetzt irgendwie eine übelste
beleidigung oder so
und guck mal bei mir ist es doch auch running gag mittlerweile dass man sagt
der max hat was weiß ich dicke arme dicke finger oder sonst was ich könnte
mich jetzt übelst drüber aufregen dass dicke leute diskriminiert werden und was
das hier alles soll und müsstest du alle sperren und anzeigen und pc ist
zerstören und sonst was oder ich denke mir einfach ist doch eigentlich ganz
lustig wenn die leute ein bisschen dummes zeug zum spammen haben selbst
haha ist gebannt ja ich kann mir das also mittlerweile ist es wirklich schwierig
sgd qd und a gd qd g fack ja also den summer games down quick und awesome
games down quick ist wirklich schwierig anzugucken halt dadurch dass die die
chat experience immer so ist wie es früher war
ja muss man jetzt muss man mal sagen das und schon sind wir mal im spot da
ei level 60 jo seit letzter woche schon oder seit wann bin ich 60 45 tage
so ist auch spaz
kann die quest gar nicht machen oder doch kann war
bling bling bling
1000 quests
gab es hier noch mehr quests der typ hervorrat noch irgendwelche sammel quests
gehabt
1000 quests beste
so sonst gibt es keine quests mehr na so bringen wir mal mein gaule zum spot
damit gebashed hoffentlich haben wir da irgendwelche spot taken body please
lief tippen
mein afi 19
im moment wo sind wir gerade ist doch der falsche spot
falsche 1000 fake 1000
wir wollen die realen 1000 former bashen
ja hier hier sind wir richtig
aber wir müssen auf die anderen seite wie kommt man hier am besten auf die
anderen seite
profis aus den kreiner am start bei der wei
nope
nope das das das das mein pferd in ruhe kacke 1000
bar food futtern sehr richtig
ja hier geht es auch genau
alter es fährt hüpft doch mal da hoch
kann man das hier um jetzt wird bestimmt gebashed wenn man das hier oben stehen
lässt
guckt 1000 1000 schnapschen
reiting skills alter fährt
ich wäre es doch noch mal schaffen heute auf dieses ding da oben drauf
mal ne runde ae machen dass alles tot ist
alles voll natürlich mit 1000 mit mit mit tippen
schön mal rein lichen
dat movement alter ja bestes
das ist halt typisch 1000 von über überfüllt ohne ende
guckt euch das mal an
das ist ja mal
ach ja im vergleich zu anderen mmos
also angemerkt ist es in bdo so dass auch graue
monster xp geben und drops geben und sowas
ist ja in vielen mmos so dass monster die quasi zu sehr unter einem im level
sind geben keine xp mehr und
kein loot mehr und und nichts mehr
aber im bdo ist das nicht so bdo gibt alles x und loot
da unten ist noch was zum kill 1000 assassin
macht die standard shake cam an die standard kamera in bdo das ist so
nervig
also die stand hat einstellung bdo erstens ist die musik übertrieben laut
von dem gelb
dazu schreien die die die charaktere noch übelst laut rum
zwar anguckt er wieder wieder wie die wird rum schreit wenn die spells war
ja
oder wissen auch
und die kamera wackelt wie verrückt
gerade no life auf 52 gekreidet 52 ist noch nicht no life
das noch ist noch im raum
ist bdo die eier legen die wollen mich sagen im bereich mmo lol man bekommt für
alles xp und level
ich finde bdo ist in vielen bereichen mal was anderes wieder
es ist halt definitiv nicht das das übliche endgame gruppen raid dungeon
feinde mmo
ich gehe mal davon aus den meisten leuten wird es deswegen auch nicht
gefallen
eben die meisten leute nach genauso was suchen
wobei ich den unterschied immer noch nicht genau verstanden habe
ob man jetzt
mob kreit macht oder quest kreit
kreit ist kreit erst mal
und die meisten mmo quest sind halt dumm
das ist der ist halt überhaupt nichts bei die meisten mmo quests
kannst du
kannst du in fünf minuten kannst du dir 30 stück ausdenken
und man muss ja in fast allen
mmo's kreiten
mal das bisschen sausen
es ist übrigens leute ist der beliebteste spot im ganzen game geht alle hin
siehst ja auch schon
wie wenig mobs hier gibt normalerweise ist hier alles voll gepackt mit mobs
ich habe jetzt übrigens hier eine bratwurst neben mir stehen
das ist sehr verlockend
ich muss mal kurz
futtern, eine schnudel aber jetzt gehts bratwurst
ich muss gerade mal meine bratwurst zu currywurst machen leute
das erfordert meine komplette aufmerksamkeit
kann ich grad ganz außen kreit machen
komm wie sie kein damage machen
bastion alter bastion alles bastion
alle quests fertig
ja das kann schon sein
dass das viele ebenso direkt vor augen haben wollen
ich mache jetzt raid
und da ist die aufgabe diesen und diesen boss zu killen
alter warum hab ich so viele zuschauer gerade
wurd ich irgendwie gehostet oder so
wartet mal
ok
da hab ich nix dagegen
das ist eigentlich weepmusik im hintergrund gerade
wir sind mit den quests fertig aber ich
ich kreisel mal in 1000s noch ein bisschen rum bis ich volle invent habe
das geht ja schnell
also du bist hier weil es langweilig auf der arbeit ist
bist du auf der arbeit heute?
oh oh oh oh
ich hab mich nicht geheilt
op was ist denn das eigentlich für ein held
ist er down was war denn das jetzt
war das ninja oder was war das ich weiß gar nicht was das für ein held jetzt
gegen was hab ich da gerade gefightet
musa ok
ich hab keine ahnung von dem game hab eigentlich
ich hab null ahnung von dem game einfach op versatz carry
ich will auch eigentlich nur meine carrywurst fortern jetzt
äh was mach ich denn hier
ja arbeit ist gut gesagt mache gerade mal neun monat zivilenz
ah wo machst du das
wenn du mir das sagen möchtest würd mich interessieren
wo machst du denn zivilenz
also nicht wie das genau heißt sondern welche welche richtung
wir machen jetzt hier noch bis inventar voll ist und dann gehen wir quests abgeben
in einem flüchtlingsheim für frauen aha
ich hab zivilenz gemacht in einer einrichtung für behinderte
also in der werkstatt war das wobei werkstatt ist zu viel gesagt
das hat halt so den anschein von der werkstatt ja und es gab auch so ein paar
sachen in dieser richtung zu tun aber eigentlich war das eher so ne
sagen wir so ne so ne art ganztags halbtag halbtag bis ganztagsbetreuung
wo man halt den leuten auch so das gefühl gegeben hat ist
es hat irgendwie gewissen wert wenn sie was machen so
ist wirklich ob das so wirklich sinnvoll war was da gemacht wurde
weiß net beziehungsweise was da halt gewerkstatt wurde
aber das war echt ne gute sache ich muss sagen
also diese sache dort zivildienst machen war wirklich hat sich wirklich gelohnt
weil ich mein es hat jeder erstmal so vor allem wenn es halt
leute also mit behinderten hast du ja normalerweise wenig kontakte
du hast doch erstmal ein bisschen berührungsängste und hast eigentlich
erstmal keine ahnung was du genau machen sollst
und so ging es mir da am anfang auch aber nach ein paar wochen
war das voll normalst überhaupt ja
du hast dann auch mit der zeit irgendwann gemerkt dass sie auch alle
unterschiedlich ticken also dass da auch nicht alle in einen
top irgendwie schmeißen kannst also das war schon nicht schlecht
das ist ne sache wo ich sagte es hat sich wirklich gelohnt es mal
gemacht zu haben
oh wir reiten jetzt zur quest abgeben kann ich meine currywurst fordern
sag mal
hoffentlich kommt hoffentlich kommt der gaul hier alleine raus
oh das ist super offending
du meinst weil weil weil ich den musa gekrieft habe obwohl er mich angegriffen hat
quailt hiding spots
ja das ansausend daneben da wo alle pferde stehen ist eigentlich der beste spot da spawnen
keine mobs
das war der neue jahres einstieg für dich bis 31 livestream ins bett gegangen dich richtig
pennen können ab 10.00 livestream um deine frage zu beantworten
also der neue jahres einstieg war bei mir ziemlich live stream ich
also richtig schön no live livestream
zu meiner überraschung waren sogar viele leute da
und wir haben richtig coole overwatch viewer games gemacht
hatten wir in einem game hatten wir
ein bronze drinne und ein top 500 also quasi wir hatten von bronze in einem game bis top
500 alles dabei
wir hatten gold dabei wir hatten platin dabei diamond dabei master dabei top 500 dabei
bronze dabei und ich glaube sogar in silber
irgendwie wir hatten ja alles dabei in einem game
und was man daran schon gesehen hat man muss overwatch im team spielen und es wollen dann
ist der rang erstmal egal
klar vielleicht mechanik mäßig gibts noch ein paar unterschiede
große unterschiede aber das wichtigste ist dass man das im team spielen will
das wollen die meisten halt im rank nicht kein bock drauf so easy 1000 quest fertig
so ich werde jetzt noch mal weiter reiten wieder nach altinova und dort meine geld
holen und nach velia bringen
ist gut kann ich nämlich ein bisschen kann ich ein bisschen rumreiten und mein essen
endlich mal reinhauen
destroyer bestell dir ne runde sushi easy
easy live
warum hast du eigentlich kein richtiges gear an
meinst du das aussehen oder was von dem held
weil ich habe relativ gutes gear an
du meinst warum ich so aussehen wie ein koch
oder ein zellados
ich sehe aus wie ein koch weil ich ein koch kostüm an habe
also kannst du den kostüm anziehen dann siehst du halt immer so aus egal was du für eine
rüstung an hast
leuchten nichts
ich bin da ich bin da meinung also ich hoffe die mystic mystic awakening hat rgb beleuchtung
dann dann werde ich mystic rerollen
weil das fehlt mir eigentlich noch eine klasse mit rgb beleuchtung in bdo
warum gab es dieses jahr eigentlich nicht wieder feuerwerk gab es letztes jahr auch
irgendwelche feuerwerk sachen die die getroppt sind von monstern oder habe ich es einfach
nur verpasst
ich sollte mal die meinem pferd auch die hufe anziehen
was ist denn rgb beleuchtung halt an computer teilen led beleuchtung
der sebaro hat wieder die beste erklärung dafür genau deswegen heißt es rgb das sind
leds
oder halt deine
hardware
unterschiedlich mit unterschiedlichen farben leuchten lassen kannst also die sinnloseste
erfindung überhaupt
ich habe sogar mittlerweile auch rgb ram
rgb beleuchte ram
hat zu 60 dange seit drei drei vier tagen schon
das bdo hatte feuerwerk in velia ok habe ich dann mitgekriegt
beleuchtung an hardware ist total sinnlos braucht wirklich keiner
es sieht halt ganz nett aus wenn man das ordentlich macht und das passende gehäuse mit fenster
drin hat und so was
aber ob sich das geld dafür lohnt kann wirklich nicht nur jeder selbst beantworten
das muss man ram aussprechen genauso wie amazon
oder bdo bdo ist klar
das erinnert mich an die diskussion früher
max es heißt nicht kott bitte sprich das cod aus
nur florian 6 26.000 262.000
aber auch kariburg fast vernichtet
es werden ganz viele leute ganz viele leute werden jetzt wach so wie es aussieht
so also nicht dass ich jetzt was vergesse
ich brauche geld aus altinova wie viel geld habe ich hier oben noch
da muss ich ok leute wir müssen noch ein stück reiten
ich nehme jetzt die ganze kohle das ist nämlich gut da kann ich jetzt während ich hier rum
reite und und hier einsammeln kann ich in ruhe essen
ich bringe die ganze kohle nach velia und dann müssen wir überlegen was wir machen
ich habe keine ahnung ehrlich gesagt
fabian bist du noch da
wir können red battlefield machen ich bin halt der absolute ober pvp noob
red battlefield quest kann man machen
fabian hast du noch eine idee was ich jetzt irgendwie machen könnte außer halt sinnlosen
grind oder red battlefield
lbf quest ok dann machen wir die red battlefield quest
im prinzip kann ich jetzt auch direkt machen weil kann man sich doch hier irgendwie drüber
anmelden
bekommst du eigentlich irgendwann mal einen sub button auf twitch
irgendwann bestimmt ja
ich hab mich noch nicht ich hab mich noch überhaupt nicht drum gekümmert muss ich
ehrlich sagen
ich muss mal kurz mein tablet mit futter rausbringen
mhb nicht mbf, mhb um mich drum herum
ne ne das war jetzt kein mbf
was haben wir jetzt? 14 Uhr
gucken wir ob der eax da ist
hopp
ja dann sammeln wir erstmal Geld ein
ich habe jetzt nämlich keine Ahnung mehr was ich machen soll
wir haben jetzt alle dailies erledigt
schon ein bisschen mobs gekreidet
zerg surfen
ja mit zerg surfen ist gemeint du bist quasi in der gruppe
von ganz vielen leuten halt im zerg
und spamst da deine aes
und stell dir halt so die schafsherde vor
oder halt die zerg
bist halt drinne und
wirst halt selbst nicht so einfach gebashed
weil halt viele leute um dich drum herum sind
deswegen zerg surfen
draufsteigen
ja
nein
ehm fabian du hast noch rl stells ne
hmhm
also wir können jetzt nichts irgendwie duo grind oder so machen
ehm ist es nicht eigentlich sinnlos eine richtig gute waffe für die main hand zu holen
mit richtig gut meine ich zacker
eh etc weil man sowieso später die awakening waffe benutzt
die stats von deiner
von deiner main hand
zählen auch in die ankäufe mit rein
die du mit deiner awakening machst
also deswegen ist sogar eines der besten sachen die du holen kannst
erstmal halt den bossstab
neujahr gut überstanden ja gut gestreamt bis 1.30
gepennt und jetzt ab 10 wieder gestreamt
also ich glaube nachdem also mir fällt jetzt wirklich nichts ein was man noch großartig machen könnten außer halt weiter grinden
aber mein bock auf weiter grinden hält sich auch irgendwie in grenzen
ich glaube ich bin da eigentlich in xp scroll
ehm
hat es jetzt vollgebracht die einzusetzen
ja wie gesagt außer ein bisschen im kreis grinden fällt mir jetzt gerade nichts großartig ein
gsrbfg ist gerade ein bisschen wenig los
deswegen tendiere ich dazu jetzt erstmal stream auszumachen und heute abend wenn der eax wieder da ist
overwatch placements zu spielen
da kann ich noch ein paar sachen vorbereiten für morgen
ich muss ja morgen wieder auf die arbeit obwohl ich sowas von überhaupt keinen bock hab
das war schlimm ey
pvp gegen leute mit ähnlichem gier
ne ich hab gerade keinen bock drauf
ich reite jetzt nach altinova
crab mein geld
parks nach velia
kauf ich buff food
ne ich glaub wir machen jetzt schluss und machen heute abend noch overwatch placements
oh no was soll ich denn jetzt in der arbeit machen
naja also wenn ihr wollt ich kann noch
ich kann noch so lang on bleiben irgendwie noch 20-30 minuten jetzt bis ich hier geld eingesammelt hab
und nach velia gebracht hab und buff food gekauft hab
ich mein das ist zwar nicht spannend aber so lang kann ich noch on bleiben
kann man nen kostenlosen medio account direkt loszocken
oder muss man was kaufen
dann kannst du dir nen test account
machen für sieben tage
und in sieben tagen
kommt man in dem game mittlerweile sogar schon relativ weit
ja stellst du easy wizard
und cryen das mal ein bisschen rum
guck mal mein worker
das ist mein worker
bis 20 uhr ja destroyer das kann sein
dass ich dann schon wieder online bin
ich würd jetzt eigentlich nur warten bis der eax online ist
dass wir dann placements machen auf
also mit
den master overwatch account
dass sowas funktioniert oder was
ja und eine sache
was mir grad noch im vergleich zu anderen mmos einfällt ist
die spielwelt wird hier
also wird laufend irgendwie erweitert
als letztes kam hier unten das gebiet dazu
da gab es vor einer weile den riesen patch mit dem
mehr hier oben
es gibt also keine addons in dem sinn
also
du musst dir dann nicht irgendwie nach einem jahre nen addon kaufen
dass du hier ins neue schneegebiet kannst oder so
z.B. muss zum storage
das heißt wenn du das game hast
hast du immer zugang zu den neuesten sachen
natürlich spekulieren die schon drauf
dass man hier im shop
dass man im shop sich zeugs kauft
da spekulieren die natürlich schon ein bisschen drauf
ja
die müssen ja auch gucken wo sie bleiben
aber wenn man es übertreibt kann man in benioh natürlich auch
übelst viel kohle reinbuttern
ja
was geht alter
was kann man am anfang machen außer
black spirit quest
ja
du musst
du suchst dir mobs und bash
sie und levels
und machst danebenbei ein bisschen black spirit quest
du kannst dir aber auch einfach auf youtube mal
ein progression guide angucken
ich bin da der falsche
aber mit quest leveln ist nicht
du kannst zwar quests machen
und kriegst da auch ein bisschen xp
und vor allem durch die mobs die du dabei killst
das ist auch ein bisschen
aber wirklich wirklich schnell leveln tust du mit quest nicht
also das zieht sich ewig wenn du jetzt irgendwie
mit quests bis 56 oder so leveln willst
in bdo musst du mobs hauen
zum leveln
guck mal nochmal ein worker der gleiche worker
mmo sucht in 2k18
naja
muss ich irgendwas machen
ach zackrasch ist in dem
ist in dem paytube
ist in dem
ach zackrasch ist in dem
ist in dem paytube
paytowin shop bundle
mit dem eagle
ist da auch
bdo nochmal als game mit drin
oder was
weil ich hab mir das bundle mit dem eagle ja auch gekauft
oder gibts noch ne möglichkeit einen 2ten eagle
zu bekommen
weil wenn es noch ne möglichkeit gibt einen 2ten eagle zu bekommen
wäre das mega geil dann könnte man den eagle nämlich upgraden
kann man die 2 eagles verkuppeln und kriegt dann vielleicht
ein tier 3 eagle
das wäre doch geil
tier 3 eagle
easy win clap gg
good job
und bringen diese
gespräche ne
ne das bringt es nicht
du musst manchmal dieses
dieses
laber game mit den npcs machen
weil du dann nur so knowledge
kriegst von manchen npcs
um eben dein
atlas hier aufzufüllen
was ist denn das teil überhaupt
war der atlas
jetzt nochmal
ja
weil du kriegst für alles was du
erforscht hast in der welt
kriegst du halt
Punkte
also kriegst du
kriegst du energy punkte
und mit energy
kannst du dann
beim nightwender zeugs kaufen
oder notes aufleveln
alles mögliche
craften, zeugs abbauen
Fabian heißt das man könnte sich
so
noch mehr eagle besorgen
und die eagle dann
verkraften
für bessere eagle
weil ich meine der eagle ist jetzt schon ziemlich op
wenn du da ein tier 3 level 10 eagle hast
wäre er noch viel geiler
OP eagle
das ding ist übelst geil
high tier eagle
das ist nice
ich meine der eagle ist eh schon mega op
also durch das hier
mehr gatherst
wenn du craftest, also wenn du abbaust
fast schon pay to win
aber das ist nice, das können wir echt machen
ja ich sehe es
ich sehe es
so danke nochmal an die ganzen follows die es heute gegeben hat
ich sehe
bei streamlabs leider nicht alle
die letzten die ich sehe ist
der
xstyx
not grizzly tv
anti borussia
existence
domtoretto911
infinit
zaijaijin
vasava
lusanda lp
killer kanicke
awesomeby94
und mehr sehe ich nicht
nur mal gucken wie lange ich on bin
4 stunden ey 4 stunden
4 stunden kreiselgrind 4 stunden dailyquest
wann kann man
endlich subs reinhauen
ja
wie gesagt ich habe mich immer noch nicht drum gekümmert
sobald wieder alles
in geregelten bahnen ist also sprich die leute
auch wieder da sind und jetzt hier neujahr und alles
vorbei ist dann werde ich mal twitch
kontaktieren
und gucken
wie das läuft
ich finde ich sehe das grad
bei mir in der stream vorschau ne
wenn nur eine zeile von dem chat da ist
dann sieht es bei der katze so richtig dramatisch
aus die guckt so die guckt dann so quasi
unter dem chat hervor so
plus dramatische belichtung
wo und wann kann man heuser kaufen
du gehst hier zu einem
zu einem node in der stadt
klickst du auf ein haus und kaufst dir ein haus
so und dann verbindest du die stadt mit dem jeweiligen node
zum beispiel dem da bei mir
oder guck mal bei velia da ist
einfacher zu sehen
in velia habe ich hier
das haus das haus
und das haus
ne
so und da habe ich
worker am start die hier arbeiten da arbeiten
da arbeiten
und da arbeiten
und das hier finde ich ist einer der besten nodes
da gibts kartoffel und kartoffel brauchst du
für bier und bier brauchst du für worker
hab ich nicht hab ich nicht
also mich hat jemand angeschrieben
von
irgendeiner marketing agentur die wohl bdo
in deutschland
vermarketing
ob wir nicht sowas machen wollen
aber ich hab mich da noch nicht weiter
drum gekümmert
also quasi bdo reflings
aber eigentlich will ich keine bdo reflings
weil ich will jetzt nicht die leute irgendwie
überzeugen das game anzufangen
weil ich weiß letztendlich
das game ist nicht für jeden was
vor allem nicht wenn man wenn man
so an die normalen mmos gewöhnt ist
und irgendwie endgame raid content
erwartet oder so da wird man halt
relativ schnell enttäuscht
das heißt eigentlich muss man schon wissen worauf man sich
einlässt
und halt mal ausprobieren
zumindest will ich die leute nicht davon überzeugen
bloß dass ich mir mal ein refling verwenden
oder so
so
jetzt erstmal schön kohle in avelia packen
nicht easy money gibts jetzt
Hier bräuchte es also ein Collect All Knopf
Ups
Crownal Armor
Nicht die Black Crystals verkaufen, okay
Also die hier, ne? Ne, die hätt ich auch so, die hab ich alle aufgehoben bisher
Ne, hab ich nicht, ich hab alle aufgehoben, deswegen sind ja auch meine Vowels so voll
Weil ich alle Vowels voll mit Black Crystals hab
Oder zumindest zur Hälfte vollgestopft mit Black Crystals
Alle aufgehoben
Was ist eigentlich aus dem Dealie mit Alienware geworden?
Wir haben uns erstmal dafür entschieden, wir machen nichts zusammen
Bis ich wieder Bock hab, mehr Content zu produzieren
Was ich jetzt im Dezember hatte, also vielleicht gucken wir dann im Januar mal
Ja, es ist für beide Seiten auch besser
Ich mein, es soll sich am Ende immer für beide Seiten lohnen, wenn man sowas macht
Und es ist für mich ein bisschen doof, wenn ich dann Alienware quasi an der Backe hab
Die ja auch wollen, dass für sie was bei rumkommt
Und ich muss dann Videos machen, obwohl ich grad keinen Bock hab und umgedreht
Deswegen haben wir uns drauf geeinigt, wir warten noch ein bisschen
Bis ich wieder mehr mach
So Leute
4,5 Stunden Stream
Ich denke mal heute Abend nochmal mit Overwatch Placements
Ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen
Und wer mir noch nicht gefollowt ist
Kann mir gerne followen auf Twitch, auf YouTube, auf Twitter
Auf ähm
Das ist eigentlich so die hauptsächlichen Plattformen, wo ich aktiv bin
Hauptsächlich YouTube, Twitter, Twitch
Und natürlich auch die üblichen Sachen
Facebook, Instagram, Tumblr, Snapchat, Patreon, Xing, Myspace, ICQ, OWL, Messenger, MSN, Knudels und Tinder
Nein, nein Leute, nicht dass das jetzt einer falsch versteht
Twitter, YouTube, Twitch
Facebook hab ich auch, weil man irgendwie halt irgendwie Facebook hat, aber Facebook ist kacke
Und wir waren jetzt Schluss
Bis heute Abend, wahrscheinlich, mal gucken ob der Eax am Start ist dann, schauen wir mal
Macht's gut, bis denn
So, das war's für heute
Und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder
Und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder beim nächsten Mal wieder bei Eax